bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2022 la parole est à
Monsieur Jean René caisse neuve
rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire
[Applaudissements]
présidente messieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président de l'arbre
Commission des affaires des commissions
des finances je suis ravi de vous
présenter les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi de finances rectificative pour
2022 beaucoup nous disaient il y a
encore quelques jours que ça n'était pas
possible et pourtant l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat sont parvenus à un
accord dans la soirée d'hier je m'en
félicite à ce titre
à ce titre je tiens à remercier les
administrateurs de la commission des
finances qui nous ont accompagnés avec
beaucoup de brio pendant cette période
et remercier également
Jean-François Husson mon homologue au
Sénat avec qui les discussions ont été
franches efficaces permettant d'aboutir
à ce résultat ce texte
issu d'un travail constructif entre les
majorités parlementaires au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale et avec les
groupes de ce Parlement doit ainsi être
promulgués au plus vite et bénéficier
rapidement à tous les Français
particulièrement au classes moyennes je
ne reviendrai pas en détail sur
l'ensemble des mesures de ce collectif
budgétaire visant à rendre du pouvoir
d'achat aux Français quelques mesures
quand même la suppression de cette impôt
injuste quelle est la redevance
télévision pour un gain de 138 euros par
an et par foyer la revalorisation du
point d'indice pour les fonctionnaires
et des minima sociaux l'augmentation des
retraites pour prendre en compte
l'inflation le prolongement du bouclier
tarifaire sur le gaz
électricité le renforcement de la remise
à la pompe sur le carburant
autant de mesures concrètes et massives
qui viennent soulager les Français dans
ce contexte si particulier oui notre
soutien est massif et à ceux qui avec
mauvaise foi et parfois un peu de
condescendance disent qu'il n'y a que
des miettes dans ce texte je leur dis
qu'un salarié au Smic gagnera 40 euros
de plus par mois en septembre qu'en
juillet avec la revalorisation de la
prime d'activité et l'augmentation du
SMIC les mêmes qui quand nous avons
baissé de 5% une allocation
nous parler de la fin du monde et quand
le gain est de 40 euros nous parle de
miettes où est la cohérence chers
collègues
à mes collègues socialistes et
communistes qu'il y a encore quelques
années un siècle pour eux défendait la
valeur travail pourquoi ne défend-il pas
ce texte qui permet quand l'entreprise
et le salarié sont d'accord d'augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat des salariés en leur
permettant de monétiser les RTT et de
bénéficier des heures supplémentaires où
est votre cohérence chers collègues à
ceux
ici probablement parce qu'il ne
connaissent pas le monde de l'entreprise
pense que c'est le Parlement qui
détermine le salaire de français je leur
dis qu'il monte aux Français
quand nous en baissant les cotisations
patronales ou créer les conditions pour
que les entreprises créent des emplois
et puisse augmenter les salaires
il n'aura échappé à personne que le
texte issu du Sénat comportait de
nombreuses divergences par rapport au
texte votés par l'Assemblée nationale je
me réjouis néanmoins que sur tous ces
points déco promis satisfaisant pour
tous et pu être trouvés mais mais nous
ne pouvions pas accepter que les
bénéficiaires des minimums sociaux
soient privés de l'aide exceptionnelle
de rentrer jamais jamais notre majorité
n'a opposé les Français entre eux de
nombreuses melures de nombreuses mesures
de notre loi vont bénéficier à tous les
Français suppression la redevance
télévisions le bouclier la prime sur le
carburant mais nous voulons aussi aider
les plus fragiles avec cette aide
exceptionnelle le compromis se trouvait
en CMP permettra à la fois au
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux et aux
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité de
percevoir
le paquet pour un achat que nous votons
compte ainsi pour 20 milliards d'euros
de mesure pourquoi 20 milliards 20
milliards c'est à la fois le montant qui
permet de préserver le pouvoir d'achat
des Français en 2022 20 milliards c'est
le Chili le chiffre qui nous permet de
maintenir de déficit à 5%. et à ceux qui
n'ont de cesse de répéter tout au long
de la discussion de ce texte que la
dette ne comptait pas à coup
d'amendement coûtant des dizaines de
milliards d'euros je rappelle que les
intérêts de la dette coûtent cette année
17 milliards d'euros de plus que l'année
dernière
ce PLF confirme bel et bien notre
prévision de déficit de 5% du PIB cette
année c'est un message essentiel pour
l'indépendance et la crédibilité de
notre pays le texte de la commission mix
paritaire
issue du travail de collaboration entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
propose des solutions ambitieuses et
concrètes face à la hausse des prix qui
pèse sur nos concitoyens c'est pourquoi
mes chers collègues je vous invite à
l'adopter
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs les députés
rassurez-vous je serai court je ne veux
pas prolonger plus que de raison des
débats parlementaires qui ont duré plus
d'une quarantaine d'heures dans cette
hémicycle souvent tard dans la nuit
parfois tôt le matin et toujours en
jouant à guichet fermé preuve de la
vitalité démocratique de la nation
française
je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier tous tous les groupes
confondus pour l'esprit de compromis qui
a présidé à nos débats sur le pouvoir
d'achat
cet esprit nous a permis de confronter
des visions économiques dont il n'a
échappé à personne qu'elles étaient
différentes voire contradictoires mais
ce qui nous a pas empêché d'améliorer le
texte initial du gouvernement
ensemble nous avons enrichi ce paquet
pouvoir d'achat par des mesures très
concrètes importantes pour nos
compatriotes et qui pour certaines ne
figurez pas ou pas pour le même montant
dans la version initiale du gouvernement
je pense à l'aide de 230 millions
d'euros pour les ménages qui se
chauffent au fioul c'est une aide qui a
été multipliée par plus de 4 par rapport
à ce que prévoyait le gouvernement je
pense à la remise à la pompe de 30
centimes d'euro sur les carburants qui
va toucher l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes à partir du 1er septembre
je pense aux mesures de valorisation du
travail dont a parlé le rapporteur
général Jean-René Cazeneuve qui sont
conformes à ce qu'a toujours défendu
cette majorité le travail doit payer le
travail doit payer bien et le travail
doit garantir la dignité de tous
la monétisation des RTT qui fait couler
tellement d'encre alors qu'elle ne fait
que accorder la possibilité à tous ceux
qui le souhaitent de transformer des
congés en rémunération supplémentaire la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui fait aussi couler
beaucoup d'encre alors qu'elle ne permet
que à des ouvriers à des travailleurs
modestes d'avoir des fins de mois moins
difficiles la réduction des charges
patronales des PME sur les heures
supplémentaires toutes ces mesures sont
inspirées par la philosophie de ce
gouvernement de cette majorité le
travail doit payer
je voudrais
adresser des remerciements très
particuliers au rapporteur général
Jean René Cazeneuve qui a fait un
travail exceptionnel pendant toute la
durée des débats merci pour votre
professionnalisme merci pour votre
constance merci pour la dignité que vous
avez donné au débat
je voudrais également
adresser mes remerciements aux
présidents de la commission des finances
Éric Coquerel qui a contribué à la bonne
tenue des débats monsieur le Président
merci
je voudrais enfin remercier tous les
députés de la majorité des groupes
Renaissance modem horizon votre
mobilisation constante nous permet de
dire aujourd'hui aux Français nous
défendons votre pouvoir d'achat
au-delà des divergences naturelles et
nécessaire en démocratie je pense que
nous devons nous féliciter d'avoir
adopté aussi rapidement des mesures pour
soulager l'inflation contrairement à ce
que certains prétendent les 100 premiers
jours du quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
ont été des journées d'action de
résultats et de décision au service de
nos compatriotes il y avait des besoins
urgents nous y avons répondu vous avez
prolongé le bouclier énergie jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 2022 nous maintiendrons
le gel du prix du gaz nous plafonnerons
le prix de l'électricité à 4% jusqu'à la
fin de l'année nous augmenterons les
remises à la pompe je veux le dire avec
beaucoup de force il n'y a aucun
équivalent en Europe de protection aussi
forte contre l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie et c'est pour cela que nous
avons le niveau d'inflation le plus
faible de tous les pays de la zone euro
nous avons également ajouté des mesures
de revalorisation revalorisation du
point d'indice des fonctionnaires
revalorisation des retraites
revalorisation de la prime d'activité
revalorisation des minima sociaux toutes
ces revalorisations sont l'illustration
de ce qu'est le modèle social français
un modèle unique fondé sur un principe
de solidarité auquel nous sommes tous
attachés dans cette assemblée nous avons
enfin à compléter ce dispositif par un
soutien dédié aux collectivités il va
s'adresser aux communes les plus en
difficulté qui peinent à faire face à la
hausse du prix de l'énergie et à la
hausse du point d'indice dans ce texte
nous n'avons laissé aucun de nos
compatriotes et aucune de nos
collectivités sur le bord du chemin la
solidarité un nom c'est le texte que je
vous propose d'adopter soit défense du
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons être d'autant plus fier
que nous avons garanti cette protection
sans laisser filer les comptes de la
Nation
malgré trois semaines de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat malgré
la redoutable créativité de certains
d'entre vous en matière de dépenses
publiques
que je salue mais que je combats nous
sommes restés à 500 millions près dans
l'enveloppe des 20 milliards d'euros
prévus je vous l'avais dit en début de
débat je vous le confirme en fin de
débat au moment où vous allez adopter ce
texte nous avons respecté les finances
publiques et nous n'avons pas acheté le
compromis nous avons construit le
compromis politique
[Applaudissements]
ce texte enfin est important parce qu'il
arrive au bon moment il soulage le
compatriotes alors que l'inflation
atteint des sommets et nous permet donc
de passer ensemble un cap difficile je
veux dire à quel point je reste confiant
dans notre capacité collective en France
comme en Europe a ramener l'inflation à
un taux raisonnable dans le courant de
l'année 2023 nous agissons chaque jour
avec le reste du gouvernement pour
prendre des mesures en matière d'énergie
de sécurité d'approvisionnement nous
pouvons compter sur les mesures prises
par la Banque centrale européenne de la
politique monétaire tout cela doit
entraîner une baisse de l'inflation dans
le courant de l'année 2023
pour terminer je voudrais rappeler qu'au
printemps dernier pour ceux qui parfois
ont tendance à l'oublier les Françaises
et les Français ont réélu Emmanuel
Macron comme président de la République
et lui ont donné une majorité
mais ils ont également voulu marquer une
autre volonté une volonté politique qui
nous appartient de respecter celle de
voir les différentes forces politiques
trouver des compromis
dialoguer discuter faire preuve de sens
d'ouverture au service unique et
exclusifs de l'intérêt de nos
compatriotes sur les textes de loi nous
venons de le faire vous venez de le
faire je souhaite que nous gardions cet
esprit pour les textes à venir de la
législature je vous remercie
monsieur le mini je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
[Applaudissements]
madame
madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
monsieur le ministre mesdames messieurs
les députés
hier soir vous avez agi pour les
Français lors de la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est tenue hier député et
sénateurs ont ensemble trouvé un
compromis sur le projet de loi de
finance rectificative pour 2022
je veux saluer les parlementaires sur
tous les bancs de cette hémicycle qui se
sont mobilisés pour faire advenir ce
texte de stabilité budgétaire et
économique et de dignité pour les
Français
pour tous les français pour chacune et
chacun de nos concitoyens ou qu'ils
vivent et quel que soit leur situation
nous agissons nous aidons chaque
Français ou qu'ils vivent puisque ce
texte et il a d'ailleurs été enrichi et
je veux saluer le député des cœurs les
députés du groupe horizon qui permettent
d'accompagner les stations services de
nos campagnes et de nos outre-mer je
salue les députés du modem et le député
Nuri qui ont permis d'aider 3,7 millions
de nos concitoyens qui se chauffent au
fioul toujours souvent en milieu rural
nous aidons chaque Français ou qu'ils
vivent puisqu'ils avec le filet de
sécurité pour les collectivités c'est en
réalité les Français qui vivent que nous
accompagnons grâce à notre méthode qui a
permis sous l'impulsion de la députée
Christine pires Boone puis ensuite au
Sénat de soutenir dès cette année les
départements à hauteur de 120 millions
d'euros les régions à hauteur de 18
millions d'euros et le bloc communal à
hauteur de 430 millions d'euros
nous aidons chaque Français quel que
soit sa situation à faire son plein
d'essence la ristourne à la pompe sera
augmentée de 30 centimes en septembre
grâce à l'accord trouvé avec les députés
LR et je veux saluer le député marlex le
président Marleix et la député Véronique
louvagi si ajouterons 20 centimes dans
les stations essence du groupe Total
soit en moyenne une économie de 25 euros
par plein pour les Français nous aidons
chaque Français quel que soit sa
situation en prolongeant les boucliers
tarifaires du gaz et de l'électricité
plusieurs centaines d'économies par an
enfin pour chaque Français c'est un
deuxième impôt qui est purement et
simplement supprimé en 5 ans la
redevance audiovisuelle après la taxe
d'habitation cette majorité est la
première de l'histoire a supprimé deux
impôts en 5 ans
ce paquet pouvoir d'achat est aussi un
grand progrès pour ceux qui travaillent
oui n'en déplaise à ceux qui ont
abandonné l'objectif de valoriser le
travail nous les accompagnons
massivement nous ne les avons jamais
oubliées nous les avons toujours
valorisés c'est le sens de notre action
depuis 5 ans et la première ministre la
répéter le travail et le plein emploi
sont l'objectif prioritaire de ce
nouveau gouvernement grâce à notre
action le travail paye mieux un
travailleur au SMIC touche dorénavant
1568 euros par mois grâce à leur
valorisation du SMIC de 8% en un an et à
celle de la prime d'activité que vous
venez de voter de 4%, il touchera
également suite au compromis avec le
Sénat un coup de pouce exceptionnel à la
rentrée pour tous les travailleurs et
notamment grâce au groupe Renaissance
ils pourront monétiser leurs congés non
pris ils pourront bénéficier d'une
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires jusqu'à 7500 euros ils
pourront toucher le forfait mobilité
durable dont le plafond a été relevé à
800 euros ils pourront bénéficier de
leur entreprise carburant défiscalisé
pour payer leur plein d'essence
ce paquet pouvoir d'achat tant enfin la
main au plus fragile au plus précaire et
les accompagne j'ai dit à l'instant que
le travail était la priorité de notre
gouvernement et de notre majorité c'est
vrai mais les Français l'ont vu et les
députés assis dans les rangs de la
majorité le savent et savent quels sont
nos valeurs quelle est notre identité
pourquoi ils sont assis sur ces bancs et
pas sur d'autres bancs le soutien au
plus fragile et dans notre ADN nous ne
transigerons jamais sur cet objectif
nous ne pouvons pas et nous ne devons
pas opposer nos concitoyens qui
travaillent à ceux qui sont exclus du
marché du travail pour lesquels nous
devons aussi agir à ceux qui affirment
qu'on est au RSA par choix qu'on reste
chômeur de longue durée par choix qu'on
recouvre au banque alimentaire par choix
bref qu'on est pauvre par choix nous
répondons que nous faisons le choix
d'accompagner les plus précaires et
c'est ce que permet ce paquet pouvoir
d'achat nous sommes fiers
de revaloriser les minimas sociaux fiers
de revaloriser les prestations sociales
c'est pour cela que nous sommes fiers
d'apporter un soutien supplémentaire
ciblé pour 10,5 millions de foyers
pauvres ou proches du seuil de pauvreté
avec une aide exceptionnelle de rentrée
fier aussi de renforcer l'action des
banques alimentaires avec un soutien
exceptionnel de 40 millions d'euros qui
a été adopté au Sénat
mesdames et messieurs la leçon de ce
PLFR c'est que la situation politique ne
nous a pas empêché d'agir pour les
Français ou ne nous a pas contraint à
revoir notre ambition politique à la
baisse au contraire si vous me le
permettrez je retiendrai deux choses de
ces journées et de ses nuits passées
ensemble sur ces bancs
tout d'abord nous avons pu et quand je
dis nous je veux parler aussi bien de la
majorité que de certains députés de
l'opposition aller plus loin encore au
service des Français Bruno Le Maire l'a
très bien dit on nous promettait un
parlement bloqué un gouvernement empêché
des Français abandonnés c'est tout le
contraire qui s'est produit le Parlement
a plus que jamais exercé sa mission de
faire la loi en y introduisant des
évolutions majeures le gouvernement et
la majorité ont respecté le mandat que
leur a donné les Français à savoir agir
pour eux sans augmenter les impôts et
sans augmenter la dette et les Français
voient que l'on avance ensemble alors
service soyons en fier
par ailleurs et je l'avais dit en juin
dernier avant l'examen de ce texte
j'avais dit qu'il serait l'occasion
d'une clarification et d'un moment de
vérité mesdames et messieurs des vérités
on bel et bien éclaté à l'occasion de se
débat
d'abord dans la méthode puisqu'il est
apparu que pour certains cette mystique
ne servait pas à faire la loi mais à
faire du bruit ça n'est pas notre
méthode
ensuite sur le fond car il est apparu
clairement que la responsabilité
budgétaire qui est impératif pour
l'indépendance de la France elle est à
trouver sur ses rangs et elle n'est pas
trouvée sur les rangs des extrêmes c'est
nous qui défendons la responsabilité
budgétaire
l'autre leçon politique c'est bel et
bien d'une forme de dérive malheureuse
dérive malheureuse d'une certaine gauche
passée à l'extrême passer d'une forme de
rêve à une triste philosophique une
gauche
[Applaudissements]
une gauche qui est passée de sous les
pavés la plage à sous le projet les
taxes qui a le bruit pour méthode et
l'enfer fiscale pour projet
ça n'est pas notre projet
Mesdames et Messieurs sachez et j'en
terminerai par là que vous avez devant
vous un ministre des comptes publics
serein et déterminé je ne peux en effet
que saluer la responsabilité qui a
présidé à l'accord qui a été conclu hier
en CMP sur 20 milliards de crédit
engagés Bruno Le Maire vient de le
rappeler ce sont 500 millions d'euros
qui se sont ajoutés pour des dispositifs
utiles nécessaires et pertinent nos
comptes n'ont pas dérapé nous n'avons
pas acheté le compromis à coups de
milliards nous l'avons construit à force
de travail d'écoute et de dialogue
nous tenons les comptes nous suivons
notre trajectoire nous respectons nos
engagements je sais que cet objectif
était cher au cœur du rapporteur général
Jean-René Cazeneuve à qui vous me
permettrait d'adresser mais sincères
remerciements mes chaleureuses
félicitations un témoignage de ma
reconnaissance et de mon amitié
je veux saluer aussi la mobilisation de
Matthieu Lefebvre pour le groupe
renaissance de Mohamed lakila pour le
groupe modem et de Lise manier pour le
groupe horizon
nous avions des lignes rouges ni des
rapages budgétaires ni hausse d'impôts
ni dette supplémentaire car agir pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Français c'est agir
aujourd'hui face à l'aplatation mais
c'est aussi les protéger demain des
conséquences d'une des routes de nos
finances publiques à double titre donc
engagement tenu promesse tenue grâce au
pouvoir du compromis à la stabilité de
nos institutions à la force de notre
engagement pour les Français poursuivant
ensemble merci beaucoup
la parole
est à monsieur Éric Coquerel président
de la commission mixte paritaire
messieurs les ministres sur le
rapporteur chers collègues messieurs les
administrateurs de la Commission de
finances que je remercie ici le texte de
loi
issu de la commission mixte paritaire
même s'il s'est conclu sur un
élargissement bienvenue de la prime de
rentrée ne change pas la logique globale
du PLF il reste construit autour de
mesures soit contre-productive soit
insuffisante soit manquante le
bouliclier tarifaire en terrine les oses
des prix précédentes l'aide au carburant
est trop faible et évite le blocage des
prix au nom d'une économie superficielle
pour les contribuables la suppression
précipitée de la redevance aux yeux
visuelle mais tout ce secteur en danger
et des milliards vont devoir être
ponctionnés sur les budgets d'autres
services publics
on ne compte d'ailleurs plus et
compensations de recettes que vous
mettez sur le dos de la TVA ce tonneau
des dalaïdes là finira par déborder les
coups de pouce ponctuels à ce que vous
appelez le pouvoir d'achat sont très
largement de ça des besoins de la
population et ce même si je dois saluer
les avancées consenti à vos oppositions
concernant la compensation financière
des collectivités locales
malheureusement pendant ce temps le
gouvernement fait le choix de continuer
à baisser les impôts de production et à
refuser toute taxation des revenus du
capital à ce sujet hier le secrétaire
général de l'ONU a lui aussi appelé à
taxer les surprofips pétroliers
rappelons-les 17 milliards ont un
semestre pour total soit deux fois plus
que l'an dernier un est déjà record
l'équivalent de l'augmentation de la
charge de la dette
vous pouvez vous pourrez dire ce que
vous voulez rien ne légitime de ne pas
imposer davantage chez profits qui
s'appuie sur l'explosion des prix à la
pompe et la spéculation sur une des
énergies les plus polluantes
nous avons trop besoin de ces recettes
ne serait-ce que pour décarboner
l'économie ne pas les taxer et
moralement politiquement économiquement
financièrement et écologiquement
intenable
j'ai lu Bruno Le Maire que vous ne
donniez raison sur l'émission sur la
fiscalité des entreprises que je voulais
lancer avec l'élégance caractérise je
rassure mes collègues de la majorité qui
l'ont laissé filtrer ce ne sera pas un
os arrangé mais là-bas sur laquelle je
suis sûr vous finirez monsieur le
ministre par devoir aussi me donner
raison maintenant je voudrais m'attarder
sur la situation et l'objectif avec
lequel vous vantez de renouer pour
justifier de payer les faire j'ai nommé
le plein emploi en tant comme de gauche
on pourrait imaginer que cet objectif me
s'y est bien pourtant je conteste
radicalement la réalité que vous
décrivez et les méthodes employées pour
prétendument y parvenir
vous décrivez une réalité à partir d'un
jeu de dupe sur les chiffres voilà des
années et plus particulièrement depuis
début 2022 que vous maquillez la réalité
de l'emploi en exagérant leur création
et en sortant des chômeurs des
statistiques par exemple on y incluant
pas les personnes ayant été radiées de
Pôle emploi soit 10 % des 10% de toutes
les sorties recensées et qui n'ont pas
pour autant trouver un travail mais
aussi en faisant des annonces de
création d'emplois qui mettent sur le
même plan les temps plein et le moindre
temps partiel de quelques heures au lieu
de présenter vos statistiques en
équivalent en plein cela paraît d'autant
plus trompeur vous admettrez que l'on
sait que les deux tiers des emplois
créés fin 2021 sont des au contrats
d'intérim dans moyenne deux semaines
d'autant qu'en plus et c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau sont depuis 2022 également
inclus dans les chiffres de l'INSEE ce
que vous appelez les emplois alternants
soit sur tous les apprentis
cela représente 240 000 des 1,2 millions
d'emplois prétendu moins créés en 5 ans
les apprentis constituent même pour le
FCE l'immense des majorités des emplois
créés entre 2020 et 2021 ces
arrangements avec les chiffres n'ont
malheureusement pas le pouvoir d'altérer
la réalité donner des emplois aux gens
n'allez pas chercher ailleurs que dans
cet écart entre vos bilans et la réalité
vécue par le pays les raisons pour
lesquelles votre bilan financier soit la
loi de règlement de budgétaire a été
battue ici même hier un fait inédit
depuis 1870
d'ailleurs vous annonce sur le plein
emploi sont contredites partout même par
l'INSEE elle-même mais aussi la Banque
de France qui prévoit autour de 7,5% de
chômage en 2027 venons-en à la méthode
j'ai nommé l'affaiblissement de toutes
les cartes de protection des salariés du
statut lui-même voilà des années que
vous dit tricotez la protection que le
contrat de travail est censé constituer
nous vous avons vu à l'offre dès 2017
lorsque vous avez doublé le plafond du
chiffre d'affaires possible pour un
auto-entrepreneur étape majeure du
développement de l'emploi ubérisé nous
vous avons vu à love avec les lois
Pénicaud la fragilisation du Code du
travail l'inversion de la hiérarchie des
normes et l'affaiblissement de
l'assurance chômage nous vous avons vu
développer sans cesse les exonérations
fiscales et sociales affaiblissant du
même geste la part socialiser des
salaires et donc des salaires dans le
partage global de la plus-value et nous
vous voyons dans ce plf.r favoriser la
défiscalisation et l'exonération des
heures sup le rachat des RTT le recours
aux primes en somme nous voyons faire
nous voyons tout faire pour que les
décisions reposent non pas sur le cas de
légal le code du travail un travail je
terminerai le présent mais uniquement
sur le bon vouloir du patron pour
conclure la marque de ce packet pouvoir
d'achat aurait été double ne pas
augmenter les salaires ne pas taxer les
dividendes c'est là votre priorité
donnée à la valeur capitale
[Applaudissements]
règlement
pour au titre de l'article
70-6 avec beaucoup de pour la courtoisie
de nos débats en réalité j'ai entendu on
a été un certain nombre à entendu à
entendre une provocation sur le ministre
qui aurait été monsieur Attal qui serait
le stagiaire de Monsieur le Maire bon
au-delà de la vision que vous pouvez
avoir des stagiaires
je trouve que si nous sommes nous sommes
dans un dans un moment et le ministre
venait de le dire monsieur le ministre
le maire venait de le dire où nous
essayons de trouver des compromis où
nous essayons de travailler ensemble où
nous essayons de faire tout simplement
ce qui est notre mandat nous mettre au
service des Français de tous les
Français quel que soit leurs idées
quelles que soient leur origine quel que
soit leur parcours je
très juste que nous méditons cela
peut-être pendant l'été et que en
septembre nous partions sur des
meilleures bases si vous voulez que nous
nous négocions ensemble arrêtons les
invictives sans cesse arrêtons les
petites insultes les petites
provocations et faisons juste une chose
mes amis faisons juste une chose notre
travail de parlementaire notre travail
de parlementaire c'est se mettre au
service des Français c'est être utile
c'est de les écouter c'est de travailler
pour eux et d'arrêter le cirque que vous
mettez dans cette émission depuis un
mois
merci mon cher collègue donc je vous
indique que j'ai reçu de Monsieur Boris
Vallot et des membres du groupe
socialiste et apparentés une motion de
rejet préalable déposée en application
de l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement
que je suis saisie sur cette motion de
rejet préalable d'une demande de scrutin
public déposée par le groupe la France
insoumise et par le groupe socialiste
c'est donc que le scrutin est annoncé
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Monsieur Michael boulot
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur messieurs
les ministres monsieur le Président de
la Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues
ce quinquennat sera-t-il le candide le
quinquennat des rendez-vous manqués
à l'issue de ce premier mois de la 16e
législature le groupe socialiste et
apparenté ne peut que faire ce triste
constat aux différentes crises que les
Françaises et les Français subissent de
plein fouet crise sanitaire crise en
Ukraine crise climatique sécheresse et
qui impacte directement ou indirectement
leur pouvoir d'achat dans un contexte
d'inflation galopante le gouvernement ne
propose que des miettes
certes il faut répondre à l'urgence par
des mesures d'urgence
mais ce qui a été proposé jusqu'à lors
et très en deçà du niveau de l'urgence
la soi-disque la loi soi-disant pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat en a été
la première cruelle illustration
pas d'augmentation
significative du SMIC vous avez parlé de
40 euros par mois monsieur le ministre
pas d'augmentation des salaires
éventualité d'une prime versée peut-être
au bon vouloir des entreprises mais sans
cotisation sociale évidemment
revalorisation des prestations
allocations et être diverses deux points
en dessous de l'inflation autrement dit
une dévalorisation
merci nous avions déjà tiré la sonnette
d'alarme quant à l'insuffisance de ces
mesures pire ce texte sur le pouvoir
d'achat en particulier par les baisses
des cotisations sociales qui
l'organisent laisse entrevoir des
milliards durablement perdus pour les
régimes sociaux une occasion en or que
le gouvernement pourrait saisir
désormais et utiliser pour détricoter
ces régimes à l'encontre l'intérêt des
Françaises et des Français à l'automne
avec les discussions sur la retraite ou
sur l'assurance chômage
or le budget rectificatif qui est le
sujet d'aujourd'hui vient confirmer ses
craintes à peine un jour après le vote
définitif du projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat
à peine le temps de respirer et ont un
éclair le gouvernement entérine une
politique de défiance à l'encontre de
nos concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens
hier soir dans une alliance assumée
entre LR et Renaissance vous avez décidé
dans ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative pour 2022 de vous attaquer
à la fraude sociale via la carte Vitale
biométrique marronnier de la droite
sénatoriale
dans le fond lutter contre la fraude
bien sûr mais là on a fort l'impression
que vous accusez les Françaises et les
Français des déséquilibres de nos
finances publiques
en réalité plutôt que d'agir sur le taux
de non recours au prestations sociales
qui concerne selon un rapport de mai
dernier de l'Assurance Maladie 5
millions de personnes le gouvernement et
ses alliés LR s'inquiète d'une fraude
qui représente
1,22% des prestations versées et qui est
surtout le fait je vous le dis mes chers
collègues du travail au noir
en parallèle l'action contre la fraude
fiscale ou là il y aurait du boulot
environ 5 à 10 fois plus coûteuse pour
ne finances publiques est au point mort
[Applaudissements]
autre marque de défiance à l'encontre
des Françaises et des Français le coup
de canif dans le code du travail
votre budget rectificatif veut permettre
la monétisation des RTT formule poli
pour ne pas dire la vérité les salariés
sont en fait inciter à vendre leurs
heures de repos à travailler plus mais
sans gagner plus dans la durée
[Applaudissements]
puisque vous refusez d'augmenter les
salaires pas d'augmentation des salaires
et attaques sur les 35 heures on
comprend l'amitié et le lien entre
Emmanuel Macron et Nicolas Sarkozy
alors certes cette vente de RTT est
limitée jusqu'à 2025 mais personne n'est
dupe vous trouverez bien là une occasion
pour pérenniser la mesure si elle n'est
pas un cavalier budgétaire car modifier
un article du code du travail au sein
d'une loi de finance mes chers collègues
soyez sûr que nous allons poser la
question au Conseil constitutionnel si
jamais ce projet est adopté
[Applaudissements]
mais au-delà du droit c'est la méthode
qui interpelle décidé d’une telle
modification du Code du travail sans
concertation aucune au détour d'un
amendement et donc à la faveur d'un
trait de plume traduit un mépris profond
et structuré pour le dialogue social et
à l'encontre des organisations
syndicales
nous avions l'habitude lors du précédent
quinquennat où vous aviez malmené les
partenaires sociaux et les corps
intermédiaires fort de votre très forte
majorité mais cette fois la situation
est différente vous nous aviez promis
une nouvelle méthode où est-elle
le ton donné et ça naugure à rien de bon
pour la rentrée et les réformes que vous
nous promettez sur les retraites ou
l'assurance chômage
ce mépris pour le droit pour les corps
intermédiaires pour les partenaires
sociaux pour les Françaises et les
Français je vous le dis est inacceptable
cela les deux ton moins que le
gouvernement et LR dans une alliance des
droites qui éclatent aujourd'hui encore
une fois au grand jour à obstinément
rejeté tous les amendements à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat pour mettre à
contribution les plus aisés
la mise en place d'un ISF climatique
refusé la contribution des hauts revenus
refusée la taxation sur les super
profits des multinationales de l'énergie
et du transport refusaient même Antonio
gutella secrétaire général de l'ONU hier
le dit il est immoral je le cite
nommément et complètement il est immoral
que les firmes de pétrole et de gaz
fassent des profits records sur le dos
des plus pauvres et avec un énorme coup
pour le climat je presse tous les
gouvernements de taxer ces profits
excessifs faisons-le
l'ONU le recommande le Royaume-Uni l'a
fait l'Italie l'a fait la Roumanie la
Hongrie l'Espagne l'ont fait et vous et
nous
vous avez fait vous avez certes fait
semblant en déposant un amendement cela
dit moins 10 ans que le nôtre
et vous l'avez retiré à la dernière
minute sacré méthode
cette taxation des profits exceptionnels
est une nécessité pour la justice
sociale pour nos financements et pour la
justice écologique également
[Applaudissements]
dans cette alliance des droites les
Françaises et les Français sont mis dos
à dos dans une logique mortifère qui
vise à maintenir la tête sous l'eau des
plus fragiles d'entre eux pour les
forcer au travail peu importe qu'il soit
partielle inadapté précaire sous-payés
ou pénible
peu importe tant que cela permet
d'afficher une baisse du chômage un
fulletin fut-elle en trompe l'oeil
ainsi la prime de rentrée exceptionnelle
de 100 euros et fort heureusement de
justesse accordée au bénéficiaires des
Minimes sociaux alors que les LR
voulaient la réserver au seul personne
touchant la prime d'activité
après avoir voulu rogner sur 3 euros de
RSA
cette tentative
d'opposer travailleur pauvres et pauvres
sans emploi étaient particulièrement mal
venu dans un contexte social et
économique où les premières victimes
sont celles et ceux qui n'ont rien et
qui ne sont pas rien pour autant sur ce
point
sur ce point vous avez reculé lorsque
vous avez été alerté que ces 100 euros
allaient être retiré aux familles des
élèves boursiers un comble
toujours est-il que cette prime de 100
euros ne permettra pas de changer la
donne pour les familles les plus
déshéritées quand on sait que le coût
mensuel de l'inflation pour les Français
est estimée en moyenne à 90 euros par
mois et par foyer selon 60 millions de
consommateurs
vous avez donc limité la casse pour les
plus fragiles je vous le dis pour un
mois un mois seulement c'est mieux que
rien Certes évidemment mais il ne semble
pas que les prix est prévu de
redescendre d'un coup le mois prochain
inutile de répondre par la liste des
revalorisations 3,5% par-ci 4% par là
quand l'inflation des 12 derniers mois
et de 6,1% et après cinq années de gel
tout cela a un nom je le répète ce sont
des dévalorisations
taxer les plus riches et redistribuer ou
donner ponctuellement des miettes à nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens les plus
pauvres le gouvernement a indéniablement
choisi la seconde option
pourtant l'augmentation des salaires il
me semble que vous y êtes favorable
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie j'en
veux pour preuve régulièrement vous
demander aux entreprises d'augmenter les
salaires on a noté vous l'avez fait en
janvier 2019 en janvier 2020 en novembre
en septembre en août 2021 et en 2022 le
28 janvier le 24 mai le 27 juin le 29
juillet c'était annuel c'est devenu
mensuel avant de devenir hebdomadaire
puis journalier une question monsieur le
ministre puisque vous êtes pour
l'augmentation des salaires et puisque
ça n'arrive pas quand vous demandez
poliment au point qu'il faut maintenant
redemander de plus en plus souvent
pourquoi refusez-vous de le faire par la
loi merci mon cher collègue non 10
minutes
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé
alors est-ce que
[Applaudissements]
non monsieur le président de la
commission des finances finalement
[Applaudissements]
non je vais
oui je peux prendre la parole je
voudrais juste compléter une chose que
j'ai un peu sabré vers la fin et je le
dis notamment à tous mes collègues de la
majorité et manifestement de la droite
si j'entendais leur réactions qui se
posent des questions sur la facilitation
donnée au rachat des RTT
aux primes à la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires très profondément
écoutez-moi chers collègues vous
réagirez après écoutez moi très
profondément il faut comprendre que
c'est accentué le lien de subordination
du capital vis-à-vis du travail mais si
parce que à partir du moment où vous
sortez du cadre de légal hebdomadaire de
travail et que vous donnez des primes ou
vous permettez de faire d'avoir recours
aux heures supplémentaires c'est d'abord
et avant tout le chef d'entreprise qui
décide de les accorder ou pas alors même
que quand on est dans le cadre
hebdomadaire du temps de travail c'est
géré par des lois par des contrats de
par des cadres hebdomadaires qui qui ont
lien avec le contrat et la loi et en
cassant ça en cassant ce contrat de
travail en réalité vous vous rendez pas
compte à quel point vous déséquilibrez
le rapport entre le capital et le
travail c'est donc tout l'inverse de la
valeur travail je disais tout à l'heure
c'est d'être d'abord le pas sur la
valeur du capital et je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas que c'est ce qui va
permettre que le pouvoir d'achat
augmente et que notamment la
consommation populaire augmente c'est
une grave erreur économique mais bon
quelque part vous êtes la fidèle au camp
que vous défendez merci je vous remercie
alors j'ai un rappel au règlement de
Monsieur Lucas
merci madame la présidente rappelle le
règlement sur le fondement de l'article
70 alinéa 5 puisque le ministre Attal
c'est comporté de manière à outrager
cette assemblée puisqu'il a qualifié les
oppositions d'extrémisme alors je ne
sais pas je crois que Monsieur Attal
devrait faire un stage en matière
d'histoire de nos institutions
d'histoire de la République
particulièrement
un quatre routes parce qu'il y a là une
injure qui méconnait la réalité
politique de cette hémicycle monsieur le
ministre même la présidente et parce
qu'il y a là et on le voit une opération
qui vise à quoi en réalité qui vise
constamment en renvoyant la gauche
républicaine Alex rende droite à
banalisé et à renforcer l'extrême droite
une opération qui vous a conduit à élire
deux d'entre eux au vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale qui vous conduit à
leur donner accès à des renseignements
secret défense et qui vous conduit
constamment dans cette hémicycle
entretenir une confusion historique
grave pour l'histoire de notre
République depuis un mois et demi vous
entretenez cette confusion ça suffit
maintenant ça suffit les injures envers
la gauche républicaine et cette
confusion vous sachez la République sur
votre passage nous ne laisserons plus
faire
[Applaudissements]
on va revenir à alors on va en revenir à
nos débats nous sommes sur une motion de
rejet préalable monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés
loin des grandes péroraisons que ma site
à croire que tout le monde a besoin de
vacances dans cette hémicycle
je voudrais simplement ne laisser aucune
ambiguïté sur la question du rachat des
RTT c'est une faculté ce n'est pas une
obligation nous ne modifions en rien la
durée légale hebdomadaire du travail qui
reste à 35 heures
et dans le fond le débat n'est pas dans
l'opposition entre capital et travail le
débat est entre obligation et liberté
nous serons toujours le camp de la
liberté
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre nous
allons maintenant
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît un peu de calme nous
allons maintenant passer aux
explications de vote 2 minutes est-ce
que c'est un réel rappel au règlement
mon cher collègue je vous écoute
madame le Président sur le fondement de
l'articles
qui dit que la motion de rejet préalable
peut durer 15 minutes et notre collègue
avait prévu 15 minutes donc je voulais
avoir savoir la raison
[Musique]
de se raccourcissement à 10 minutes je
vous invite mon cher collègue à lire
l'article 108 de notre règlement qui se
situe à la page 80 et qui indique en son
alinéa 2 que la durée de l'intervention
prenait à l'appui de la motion ne peut
excéder 10 minutes à partir de la
deuxième lecture
donc la parole
[Applaudissements]
et oui le règlement se lit jusqu'au bout
la parole est à Monsieur Patrick Etzel
pour le groupe les républicains pour des
durées de 2 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente évidemment notre groupe est
en total opposition avec cette motion de
rejet de toute évidence cette motion de
rejet à un seul objectif c'est de faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de prise en
considération de l'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens et
surtout je voudrais insister sur un
point ou véritablement notre groupe
parlementaire étant total l'opposition
avec les principes défendus dans cette
motion de rejet parce que dans cette
motion de rejet manifestement vous ne
tenez pas compte de la valeur travail
encore une fois c'est très clair vous
avez un problème avec les gens qui
veulent travailler nous considérons que
cette question est essentielle et donc à
partir de là et bien nous ne pouvons que
rejeter évidemment cette motion de rejet
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul
Mattei pour le groupe modem oui merci
madame la Présidente
je suis très étonné que le groupe
socialiste dépose une notion de rejet
franchement au stade où on en est nos
discussions on a bien travaillé à
l'Assemblée notamment avec Christine
périsson sur des atterrissages sur des
textes notamment la compensation en
matière de collectivité territoriale on
a eu une CMP le Sénat s'est exprimé il a
fait des apports
j'avoue que je suis un peu étonné qu'on
soit sur une motion de rejet mais bon
c'est comme ça c'est prévu par les
textes il y a aucun problème on va
respecter le règlement et la pratique de
notre de notre assemblée simplement nous
le groupe modem on a envie de voter ce
texte pourquoi parce qu'il améliore le
pouvoir d'achat des Français 44
milliards il y a des retraités qui vont
trouver leur retraite augmentée de 4%
on a la location de rentrée qui va
pouvoir s'appliquer on a prévu la
nationalisation d'EDF ça devrait plaire
à certains pour donner les moyens si si
c'est une forme 100% du capital c'est
une nationalisation voilà donc on a
plein d'éléments positifs dans ce texte
qui répondent à l'urgence immédiate on
pourra monsieur le président de la
commission des finances vous avez été
très présent et très actif au cours de
ce débat je crois qu'on a une loi de
finances qui nous attend on a un bel
effet 16 qui nous attend on pourra
débattre sur le fond sur plein de sujets
qui ont été évoqués donc ça sera le
moment aussi de réfléchir je pense que
c'est un texte d'urgence qui répond une
attend des Français et nous le gros
modèle nous serons très heureux de le
voter donc on pourra pas évidemment
accompagner cette notion de rejet je
vous remercie pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur Arthur Delaporte
merci madame la Présidente
qu'il soit dit que les représentants de
la nation ont décidé que l'impôt sera
payé par tous les individus du royaume
dans la proportion de leur revenu que
toutes les charges publiques seront à
l'avenir supportées également par tous
j'aurais pu rajouter et toutes
le 4 août 1789 il y a 233 ans jour pour
jour le vicomte de Noailles émettait ce
vœu quelques heures plus tard les
privilèges étaient abolis
si le groupe socialiste est apparenté
présente aujourd'hui cette motion c'est
parce que nous considérons que ce texte
n'est pas satisfaisant parce qu'il
n'abolie pas les privilèges que pour
aussi tout ce qu'il passe sous silence
les inégalités ce que le texte abolite
en revanche c'est une forme
d'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
avec la fin de la redevance un impôt
imparfait et injuste mais remplacé par
un impôt encore plus injuste la TVA ce
que les textes abolis c'est le principe
du droit au repos avec votre
monétisation sans condition sans
dialogue social des RTT ce que veut
texte abolit donc c'est l'esprit même
des 35 heures
ce que votre texte passe sous silencer
donc la réalité des inégalités avec vos
primes au bon vouloir de l'employeur
vous donner à un petit nombre à un
cadeau ponctuel qu'en doutes demandions
une augmentation durable des salaires ce
que votre texte passe sous silence c'est
donc la réalité des privilèges et des
inégalités 6% d'inflation sur un an 4%
de revalorisation au mieux qui paiera la
différence les plus précaires les
retraités les bénéficiaires des minima
l'autre trou béant de ce texte c'est
bien le maintien des privilèges le refus
absurde et isolé à l'échelle planétaire
on parlait de l'ONU tout à l'heure de
taxer les super profits indécent des
multinationales qui s'enrichissent avec
la hausse des prix d'énergie un refusé
responsable l'idéologie plutôt que la
lutte contre les rentes votez cette
notion avec nous merci la parole est à
madame Lise manier pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues nous examinons cet après-midi
ce texte ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative tel qui suit de la
commission mixte paritaire ce qui
signifie qu'il s'agit donc d'un texte
issu d'un réel travail parlementaire
député et sénateurs sur chaque point
abordé dans son texte on l'augmente et
apporter leur pierre à l'édifice alors
certes cela nécessite que le cap soit
bien celui de construire des solutions
dans l'intérêt des Français dans
l'intérêt de la protection des plus
fragiles de la lutte contre les
inégalités sociales et territoriales et
protéger les Français face à l'inflation
certes il ne faut pas que le cap des
députés est sénateurs qui ont souhaité
travailler sur ce texte soit celui du
dogme de la politique politicienne ou du
buzz médiatique
face à l'urgence
à laquelle font face nos concitoyens
face à l'urgence que nous avons
d'adopter ce texte cette notion de rejet
aujourd'hui ce jeudi 4 août
objectivement nous laisse
particulièrement circonspect et c'est
pour cela qu'évidemment les députés du
groupe horizon et apparentés de la
voteront pas
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Cyrielle
châtelain pour le groupe écologiste
madame la Présidente chers collègues je
crois que personne n'est dupe du double
discours qui est en train de se mettre
en place d'un autre d'un certain côté on
prône le discours la nouvelle méthode et
de l'autre on nous insulte dans cette
émission constamment régulièrement tous
les jours les ministres les députés et
ces insultes elles ont une seule raison
c'est qu'en fait vous n'assumez pas si
nous sommes l'extrême gauche alors vous
êtes encore le en même temps sur lequel
vous avez fait campagne alors que la
vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui votre
politique elle est à droite elle est à
droite et c'est là qu'elle regarde elle
ne protège pas nos concitoyens ce double
discours est extrêmement clair au-delà
de vos insultes c'est le refus du
dialogue des propositions nous en avons
fait ici sur ces bancs nous avons dit
oui il y a une urgence sociale il y a
une urgence climatique dans l'été qu'on
est en train de connaître avec les
incendies avec les sécheresses avec les
canicules aucune de nos propositions n'a
été repris pas d'argent pour le train
partageant pour la rénovation des
logements pas d'argent pour changer les
chaudières au fioul mais mais le fioul
justement nous sommes pour aider les
gens pour changer leur chaudière rien
pour eux rien pour eux aucune musique et
aucune mesure qui permettra dans le
temps d'être protégé et enfin la liberté
mais voyons effectivement quand on
refuse de reconnaître les gens pour le
travail qu'ils font qu'on refuse de les
payer pour le travail qu'ils font quand
ils ne peuvent plus boucler leur fin de
mois c'est bien facile de leur dire
renoncer à vos RTT renoncer à vos temps
en famille renoncer à vos engagements ce
n'est pas de la liberté c'est de la
contrainte c'est pourquoi nous voterons
cette notion de rejet
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Soumia Bourou à
merci merci mon intervention va être
courte mais précise compte tenu compte
tenu du caractère dangereux concernant
l'indépendance de notre service public
audiovisuel de la suppression de la
contribution audiovisuel public compte
tenu du caractère rétrograde de la
monétisation des RTT et de la hausse du
plafond de défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui porte un coup
important au 35 heures comme il a été
dit et Roady compte tenu de l'absence
des mesures sociales pour toute une
partie de nos concitoyens et notamment
les jeunes et les travailleurs modestes
compte tenu de votre refus systématique
lors de l'examen des lois de finances de
taxer les super profits des grandes
entreprises qui se sont enrichies durant
la crise le compte n'y est pas et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous voterons
cette motion de rejet
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Charles de Courson pour le
groupe liotte
mes chers collègues
est-ce que voter cette motion de rejet
est une bonne idée bah non
pourquoi
parce que si on la vote les pensions les
prestations sociales ne seront pas
réévaluées de 4% au premier juillet et
parce que les fonctionnaires ne
bénéficieront pas des trois et demi pour
cent d'augmentation et qu'il faudra
attendre le 1er janvier le vote de la
loi de finances et le loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour les
réévaluer alors vous avouez c'est quand
même pas une très bonne idée il y a une
deuxième raison c'est dire que le
gouvernement ne veut pas d'augmentation
des salaires dans le privé c'est faire
croire que c'est le gouvernement qui
fixe les salaires dans le privé mais ça
n'est pas le cas
à part à part le SMIC mes chers
collègues à moins de nationaliser toutes
les entreprises privées c'est peut-être
ce que souhaite certains et bien voilà
et donc ce n'est pas raisonnable et puis
dernier point ce texte il est imparfait
mais il est le fruit d'un compromis
alors ne nous y opposons pas
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Robert pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues avec cette
super fêtatoire motion de rejet la
gauche de cette hémicycle la chèvre ce
premier site parlementaire comme elle
l'a commencée
en se ralliant au bruit et à la fureur
en s'alliant à ceux qui pensent plus au
followers qu'au travailleur
on se on se demande vraiment mes chers
collègues quel français vous pensez
représenter et à quel français vous
pensez parler aux Français qui
travaillent dur et qui scrutent leur
compte en banque des le début du mois
ils verront le prix de l'essence baissé
leur déplacement mieux pris en charge et
ils pourront travailler plus pour gagner
plus car cette majorité a subâtir les
grands compromis nécessaires pour les
aider
aux Français qui ont travaillé leur
retraite seront revalorisées comme tous
les Français ils ne paieront plus la
redevance télé et il bénéficieront du
bouclier sur les prix de l'énergie aux
Français qui assurent la continuité de
nos services publics le gouvernement a
dégelé le point d'indice le Ségur de la
santé s'étend désormais plus largement
aux professionnels du secteur
médico-social ce sont des promesses
tenues mes chers collègues aux Français
les plus modestes
les aides au logement seront augmentés
les demandeurs d'emploi seront
accompagnés l'aide de rentrer scolaire
sera majorée car cette majorité a tenu
bon pour ne laisser aucune famille sur
le bord du chemin
alors oui en 6 semaines
les Français ont vu la nupes empêcher
taxer bloqué et ils ont vu cette
majorité rassembler écouter concilier et
avancer
c'est pour cela que le groupe
Renaissance votre a naturellement au
compte cette motion car la vie des
Français mes chers amis vaut mieux que
les petits profits politiciens de la
France insoumise
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Aymeric salmon
pour le rassemblement national
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur comme hier l'extrême gauche
nupes oublie pourquoi nous sommes tous
présents ici défendre les intérêts des
Français et non pas freiner les maigres
avancées obtenues oui bien sûr les
avancées sont maigres mon collègue qui
interviendra sur le texte détaillera la
position de notre groupe mais cette
notion cette notion de rejet n'a qu'un
seul but empêcher les Français d'obtenir
ces maigres avancées vous n'avez
toujours pas saisi les besoins de nos
concitoyens chaque avancée si petite
soit elle ne veut pas attendre pour
arriver concrètement dans la poche des
Français c'est indispensable il le
réclame pour Monsieur le Ministre Attal
je vous mets au défi de trouver un vote
du groupe rassemblement national durant
cette discussion s'opposant à des
avancées concrètes pour le pouvoir
d'abord d'achat des Français nous avons
même fait beaucoup de propositions vous
refuser vous semblez l'oublier vos
propos mesquin ne nous empêcheront pas
de voter contre cette notion de rejet je
vous remercie merci beaucoup et pour
terminer la parole est à Madame Marianne
Maximy pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente alors notre
groupe votre évidemment pour cette
motion de rejet car nous pensons qu'on
peut faire évidemment bien mieux en ce
jeudi 4 août nous aurions pu comme il y
a 233 ans réaliser un vote historique
nous aurions pu mettre fin au privilège
des multinationales qui réalisent des
bénéfices records en profitant de la
crise que nous subissons
vous privez l'état de recettes
supplémentaires dont les classes
populaires ont grandement besoin cela
vous permet d'esquiver les vrais débats
sur le pouvoir d'achat avec cette
formule habituelle et agaçante il n'y a
pas d'argent et ce n'est pas le moment
ce n'était pas le moment d'augmenter le
SMIC ni de bloquer les loyers le
rassemblement national de demander des
votes où ils n'ont pas voté dans le sens
des classes populaires les voilà vous
avez refusé l'augmentation du SMIC vous
avez refusé le blocage des loyers
quant à droite on nous dit que nous
n'aimons pas le travail nous nous
battons pour que justement le travail
soit justement rémunéré et vous avez
voté vous aussi contre tout le long de
l'examen du texte alors nous voterons
contre ce texte et pour cette motion de
rejet car c'est un texte de régression
sociale notamment avec la monétisation
des RTT qui enregistre en catimini la
fin des 35 heures nous voterons aussi
pour cette motion de rejet car ce texte
met fin à l'indépendance du service
public de l'audiovisuel et nous voterons
pour cette motion de rejet car oui nous
le redisons ce ne sont que des miettes
qui ne compensent même pas l'inflation
et depuis trois semaines nous assistons
à une clarification politique à celles
et ceux qui pensaient que ce nouveau
mandat serait différent la réponse est
non vous avez choisi de vous alliez avec
la droite des républicains et avec
l'extrême droite du rassemblement
national vous continuez à gouverner avec
et pour les riches vous n'avez pas
respecté ce Parlement quand vous êtes
minoritaire à 18h vous faites Roboter à
2h du matin vous coiffez la démocratie
de donc vous vous trompez nous voterons
pour cette motion de rejet
je vous remercie
donc nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin
pour mettre voilà la motion de rejet
préalable je vous prie de regagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et Claude
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 329
exprimés 329 majorités 165 pour 75
contre 254 la notion de projet préalable
n'est pas adoptée
avant d'appeler la première oratrice
inscrite en discussion générale je vous
rappelle que pour la lecture des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire les interventions dans la
discussion générale valent explication
de vote
vous avez donc 5 minutes par orateur et
le premier orateur sera Madame Véronique
louvagi
[Applaudissements]
on est content d'arrêter ce soir
je remercie les collègues qui quittent
les mystiques de faire dans le calme
afin que notre oratrice puisse commencer
son propos
dans un silence respectueux
allez-y ma chère collègue très bien
Madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
les députés les républicains ont fait du
pouvoir d'achat des Français la priorité
absolue de ce début de quinquennat et ce
dans une période rendue extrêmement
compliquée par la flambée des prix du
carburant et une inflation record que la
France n'avait pas connu depuis 40 ans
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au
moment de débuter l'examen de ce PLFR
les députés les républicains conditionné
leur vote à l'attitude du gouvernement à
l'égard de nos propositions et aux
avancées que nous serions en mesure
d'obtenir c'est dans le cas de nos
positions utiles au service des Français
que nous avons tout de suite et très
vite afficher nos exigences prioritaires
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français au
terme de négociation serrée avec madame
la Première ministre avec vous même
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances puis au terme le débat très
intense à l'Assemblée et au Sénat les
résultats sont incontestables les
députés les républicains ont su faire
adopter un grand nombre de mesures
importantes et ont joué un rôle décisif
au service du pouvoir d'achat des
Français dressons rapidement le bilan de
ce que nous avons arraché au
gouvernement et finalement obtenu notre
première priorité c'était de faire
baisser fortement les prix à la pompe
nous avons dû être très ferme mais les
résultats sont là puisque nous avons
obtenu un effort bien plus conséquent de
l'État sur le prix du carburant grâce au
parlementaire LR tous les Français tous
les Français vont bénéficier d'une
ristourne de 30 centimes de l'État sur
le prix de l'essence et du diesel cette
histoire s'ajoutera par ailleurs au 20
centimes de remise consentie par Total
remise Constantine d'ailleurs sous la
pression des députés LR qui menaçaient
de faire adopter un amendement pour
taxer les profits pétroliers au total
c'est 50 centimes de ristourne sur les
prix à la pompe que les députés les
républicains ont obtenu
nous avons également obtenu une aide
exceptionnelle de 230 millions d'euros
pour aider les 3 millions de foyers qui
se chauffent au fioul un dispositif
supplémentaire de 30 millions d'euros à
destination des stations-service en zone
rurale et très éloignée des raffineries
le doublement de l'indemnité
kilométrique de 200 € à 400 € que
peuvent verser les employeurs à leur
salariés la possibilité pour les
bénévoles de bénéficier du même barème
sur les indemnités kilométriques que les
salariés la deuxième priorité des
députés les républicains c'était de
mieux rémunérer le travail parce que il
faut que le travail rapporte toujours
plus que l'assistanat là encore les
avancées sont réelles les salariés
auront la possibilité de convertir leur
RTT non pris en salaire net et ce
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2025 le plafond des
heures supplémentaires des fiscalisées
sera relevé de 5000 euros à 7500 euros
et les charges patronales seront
allégées sur ces heures supplémentaires
afin d'asser les employeurs en proposer
plusieurs salariés en somme c'est le
retour du travailler plus pour gagner
plus cher aux républicains enfin notre
troisième priorité c'était de financer
ces mesures de pouvoir d'achat par des
économies ou des baisses de dépenses il
était en effet inconcevable pour les
députés les républicains d'alourdir
encore davantage notre dette déjà
abyssale or nous avons obtenu une très
grande avancée avec la mise en place de
la carte Vitale biométrique c'est une
mesure fondamentale que les députés les
républicains portent depuis cinq ans
pour mieux lutter contre la fraude au
fausses cartes vitales qui coûtent plus
de 5 milliards d'euros chaque année à la
sécurité sociale je ne reviendrai pas
sur la déconjugalisation de la location
adulte handicapé qui est une véritable
avancée pour les 270 000 personnes en
situation de handicap qui vivent en
couple j'ajouterai quelques victoires
telles que le soutien de 750 millions en
collectivités pour les aider à faire
face à la hausse du prix l'énergie ou la
compensation intégrale au Département de
la hausse de 4% du RSA finalement ce PLF
n'est plus un texte du Gouvernement
c'est devenu un texte du Parlement
fortement inspiré des propositions et de
revendications des républicains et je
m'en réjouis et nous nous en réjouissons
cela confirme plus que jamais et c'est
le principal enseignement de ses
premières semaines de la nouvelle
législature que les républicains sont la
seule opposition
utile aux français contrairement au
rassemblement national et à la nupesse
nous ne sommes pas dans la vocifération
stérile nous nous battons nous nous
battons pour obtenir des mesures que
nous avons porté qui valent la peine car
elle profite aux Français elles
profitent à la France mais si eux les
ministres mes chers collègues engagés
dans l'opposition comme nous l'avons
hier prouvé en votant contre le projet
de loi de règlement des comptes 2021
nous continuerons de le prouver nous
continuerons de le prouver en restant
fidèle à nos valeurs c'est-à-dire
s'opposer se battre pour engranger
d'avancer pour les français pour le
service de l'intérêt général Ford et
succès en danger par les républicains
pour les Français nous voterons pour ce
PLFR je vous en remercie merci beaucoup
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Mohamed Aquila
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
je m'adresse d'abord à tous nos
collègues qui ont voté par inadvertance
contre le PGL pouvoir d'achat mercredi
voici aujourd'hui avec ce PFR votre
session de rattrapage
revenons à l'instant sur les principales
mesures pour protéger une concitoyens du
retour de l'inflation je n'en citerai
que quelques-unes comme la
revalorisation de 4% des pensions de
retraite des minima sociaux et des aides
au plus fragiles la revalorisation de
3,5% du point d'indice des trois
fonctions publiques la suppression de la
contribution l'audiovisuel public ou
encore la prolongation et
l'élargissement de la prime Macron
deuxième
nos discussions et notre travail commun
avec les sénateurs qui nous ont permis
d'aboutir à deux CMP conclusives je
pense bien sûr à la déconjugularisation
de la hache dans la loi pouvoir d'achat
mais aussi attend d'autres dispositifs
que nous sommes appelés à voter
aujourd'hui en premier lieu je voudrais
citer ceux en faveur des travailleurs
vous savez tous l'attachement du groupe
démocrate à une meilleure rémunération
du travailleur nous saluons ainsi la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires jusqu'à 2000 jusqu'à
7500 euros la possibilité de monétiser
les RTT jusqu'en 2025 nous donnant le
temps d'évaluer cette mesure ou encore
l'ouverture de la prime exceptionnelle
de rentrer non seulement au
bénéficiaires des miniats sociaux mais
aussi à ceux qui travaillent et qui
touchent la prime d'activité nous sommes
aussi fiers d'avoir réussi à vous
convaincre chers collègues et en
particulier nos collègues du groupe
renaissance de l'utilité d'ouvrir la
prime transport à l'ensemble des et en
doubler le plafond de la part carburant
et en permettant le cumul avec le
remboursement d'un abonnement de
transport en commun ce qui doit
encourager la multimodalité vrai chemin
d'avenir je ne peux citer ici les
nombreuses autres mesures mais je
m'arrêterai un instant sur les mesures
de compensation aux collectivités ça lui
ont d'abord le travail mené en la
matière à l'Assemblée à l'initiative
notamment de nos collègues Christine
Perez bonne Charles de Courson Véronique
louvagier et du rapporteur général Jean
René Cazeneuve qui nous a permis
d'atteindre un consensus qui nous a
semblé juste et bon
nos collègues sénateurs ont voulu aller
plus loin en augmentant les critères
départ le brutes se recèdent réelles de
fonctionnement de 10 à 22%
triplan triplan quasiment le coût du
dispositif que nous avions adopté et au
vu de l'augmentation en 2022 en 2023 de
leur recette nous nous questionnons sur
l'opportunité d'une telle mesure tâchons
dans nos discussions de rester
raisonnable et c'est avertissement vaut
aussi bien pour notre majorité et que
parce que charité bien ordonné commence
par soi-même également à notre groupe
cette loi de finance rectificative est
une loi d'urgence et c'est comme ça que
nous n'avons abordé cela ne doit
cependant pas
occulter les enjeux futurs ni dévier de
nos objectifs de bonnes gestion des
deniers publics permettez-moi
d'andresser quelques priorités pour les
prochaines années notre groupe réaffirme
son appel à rationaliser la dépense
publique sur le temps long en
poursuivant les réformes structurelles
qui seul garantiront le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages nous devons aussi réfléchir
plus largement à des réformes fiscales
structurelles pour mieux accompagner
l'innovation et la prise de risque sans
toutefois oublier la notion de justice
il est de notre responsabilité de
continuer dans notre volonté de
transformer l'économie tout en tirant et
le son de ce qui n'a pas fonctionné au
cours des dernières décennies nous
devrons enfin accélérer la transition
écologique et énergétique rénover les
logements qui sont les premiers
consommateurs d'espace et d'énergie
encourageant les investisseurs vertueux
et en aidant les particuliers à mieux
s'équiper en augmentant ma prime rénov
et en facilitant le changement de
chaudière voilà cher mais chers
collègues nous sommes un parti de
gouvernement et c'est avec esprit avec
cet esprit responsable avec cet esprit
constructif que nous voterons pour ce
texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
rappel au règlement allez-y
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président de la Commission monsieur
le rapporteur une remarque est-ce que
vous pourriez rappeler à certains de nos
collègues sur la base de l'article 70-3
qu'on peut avoir des débats sans
s'ajurier notamment quand on demande à
un de ses collègues quand est-ce qu'il
ferme sa gueule en français dans le
texte on pourrait oui d'accord mais on
était pas obligé d'être un jurieux par
la suite voilà donc mon collègue Le Fur
pourrait peut-être apprendre à un
certain âge même s'il y a des plus
jeunes dans l'assemblée qui ont
peut-être pas forcément de savoir vivre
pouvoir débattre sans injurier je pense
que ça serait une bonne chose dans le
respect de tous merci je crois que
[Musique]
c'est moi il serait heureux
effectivement que ça puisse être le cas
Monsieur Le Fur merci madame la
Présidente simplement il conviendrait
que nos nouveaux collègues après à
écouter les uns et les autres et ceux-ci
vont aussi pour les députés RN je n'ai
pas le son à recevoir et je n'ai pas
l'intention d'en recevoir
merci donc nous allons pouvoir écouter à
présent notre collègue pierrisbonne pour
le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues voilà nous y
sommes nous allons donc là la discussion
sur le paquet pouvoir d'achat avec le
vote définitif sur ce budget
rectificatif malheureusement je le
crains nous n'avons rien réglé sur le
fond car croyez moi les problèmes seront
toujours là à l'automne car face à des
problèmes structurels vous répondez par
des mesures conjoncturelles des primes
d'échecs des exonérations de cotisations
des défiscalisations qui en plus de ne
rien régler de manière pérenne
affaiblissent le financement de nos
services publics et de notre protection
sociale je commencerai toutefois par un
point positif de ce PLFR LED qui sera
apportée aux collectivités impactées par
l'inflation car elles aussi comme les
ménages comme les entreprises la
subissent le Sénat a amélioré
l'amendement socialiste votée en
première lecture ici et je veux
remercier le gouvernement
le ministre Bruno Le Maire pour leur
écoute mais surtout aussi pour la
méthode de travail je tiens néanmoins
aujourd'hui à vous alerter monsieur le
ministre et je l'ai dit à votre cabinet
je l'ai même écrit le taux retenu de
baisse de 25 % de baisse de l'épargne
brute entre 2022 et 2021 pour être
éligible pour jeudi bien pour être
éligible me paraît trop élevé et je
crains au final que le filet ne concerne
que peu de monde mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en discuter puisque vous
avez accepté qu'on continue les
discussions au sein d'un groupe de
travail trans partisan et je vous en
remercie ce compromis trouvé sur les
collectivités ne saurait faire oublier
les graves lacunes de ce projet de loi
de finances rectificative projet qui ne
rectifie rien aux inégalités de notre
société accentuée par le contexte
inflationniste qui tord le bras au code
du travail et qui met en péril
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
l'inflation est estimée par vous-même à
6,5 en juin or toutes les
revalorisations prévues le son bien en
dessous nous aurions préféré des hausses
de revenus des hausses de pension des
oses de minima conforment à l'inflation
outre que c'est la seule façon de
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat c'est bon
pour l'économie réelle et c'est bon pour
les recettes de l'État
quant aux côtes du travail permettez-moi
de citer la sénatrice LR hier soir nous
assumons parfaitement de mettre un coin
dans les 35 heures en laissant la
liberté aux salariés de convertir les
jours de RTT non pris en salaire mais en
réalité vous ne laissez aucun choix aux
salariés pour la plupart il renonceront
au RTT durement gagné car s'ils en ont
c'est qu'il bossent 40 heures ou plus et
parfois la nuit ceux qui veut dire que
ce repos leur est nécessaire mais parce
qu'ils voudront maintenir à tout prix
leur pouvoir d'achat et parce que vous
leur refusez une augmentation des
salaires ils n'auront d'autres choix que
de renoncer à leur temps de repos
permettez-moi aussi de revenir sur des
propositions de LR et du rassemblement
national qui visait à ne pas revaloriser
le RSA comme les autres minima ou encore
à substituer à la prime exceptionnelle
de 100 euros pour tous les minimas une
prime de 150 euros pour les salles
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité
c'est vraiment mes connaître le public
qui survit qui survit grâce au RSA
connaissez-vous le nombre d'agriculteurs
qui perçoivent le RSA aujourd'hui tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont peu de
revenus je fais le pari que non sinon
vous n'oseriez pas faire ces
propositions je ne reviendrai pas sur la
contribution à l'audiovisuel Pully
public pardon et sa suppression sur
laquelle nous nous sommes farouchement
opposés au nom de l'indépendance du
secteur il nous faut une réforme
monsieur le ministre une réforme
concertée et nous faisons des
propositions il n'y a aucune urgence sur
le sujet entendez nous
enfin et dernier point qui justifierait
à lui seul notre vote contre le
dogmatisme dont vous faites preuve
vis-à-vis des entreprises qui parce
qu'il y a de l'inflation et uniquement
parce qu'il y a de l'inflation font des
profits extraordinaires et que vous
refusez de mettre à contribution après
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
après la Commission européenne après le
secrétaire général de l'OCDE c'est au
tour du Secrétaire général de l'ONU
d'appeler les États à surtaxer les
profits allez-vous enfin entendre cet
appel
en conclusion je dirais que vous êtes
dur avec les faibles et doux avec les
forts voilà ce qui résume votre
politique qui en devient caricatural on
s'en prend au chômeur on s'en prend au
bénéficiaire des aPL on s'en prend au
bénéficiaire du RSA au bénéficiaire de
l'Ame au smicard et on dort l'autre et
on dort l'autre les grands patrons à
coups de suppression de l'ISF de cadeaux
fiscaux merci beaucoup le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour sauver notre économie et
soutenir les salariés étaient
indispensables mais aujourd'hui ils
peuvent participer à titre exceptionnel
merci
la parole
est à madame Lise Magnier pour le groupe
horizon
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
le groupe Horizon est apparenté se
réjouit de l'accord trouvé hier soir en
commission mixte paritaire entre député
et sénateurs il prouve à nouveau s'il le
fallait que l'approche transpartisane et
l'envie de construction parlementaire
permet d'obtenir des compromis dans
l'intérêt des Français je tiens en
premier lieu à remercier féliciter notre
rapporteur général du budget
pour son engagement et l'énergie qu'il y
a consacré
l'accord de la CMP est d'autant plus à
souligner que ce texte est absolument
nécessaire
nécessaire d'abord parce qu'il permet de
financer les mesures de protection du
pouvoir d'achat bouclier tarifaire sur
le gaz et l'électricité être carburant
revalorisation du régime général des
retraites et des prestations sociales
augmentation du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires ce sont bien 20 milliards
d'euros que nous engageons pour
permettre aux Français de faire face à
l'inflation il est nécessaire aussi
parce que le texte présenté par le
gouvernement a été enrichi par nos
assemblées ce texte de compromis reprend
un dessin les apports de chacune des
deux chambres parlementaires le groupe
Horizon est à parenté a pris toute sa
part dans l'enrichissement de ce projet
de loi nous voulons évidemment
poursuivre l'effort de revalorisation du
travail menée par les gouvernements
successifs et la majorité depuis 5 ans
et c'est pour cette raison que nous
avons soutenu l'augmentation du plafond
de défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la possibilité donnée
aux salariés de monétiser leur RTT et la
revalorisation des tickets-restaurants
et des indemnités repas le travail
parlementaire sur le soutien apporté aux
collectivités territoriales a également
été d'une grande qualité et je veux
saluer au nom du groupe horizon et à
parenté le travail mené également par le
rapporteur général et le gouvernement
pour parvenir à un compromis à
l'Assemblée nationale puis au Sénat le
dispositif permettra notamment aux
petites communes les plus en difficulté
de bénéficier d'un filet de sécurité
pour faire face à l'augmentation
contrainte de leurs dépenses c'est un
message fort que le Parlement envoie aux
collectivités territoriales leur
prouvant encore une fois que l'État sait
être à leur côté lorsqu'elles en ont
besoin
notre groupe a enfin beaucoup travaillé
sur la thématique de la fracture
territoriale et c'est en ce sens que
nous avons porté dès l'examen du texte
en commission des finances des
amendements visant à mettre en place un
dispositif de soutien à nos concitoyens
qui se chauffent Tokyo le plus souvent
situé dans les zones rurales ceci n'ont
pas pu bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire
qui s'applique au gaz et à l'électricité
nous sommes donc particulièrement
satisfaits que l'aide pour le fioul se
trouve dans ce texte final et nous
réitérons notre demande d'être associée
à la réflexion sur les modalités
pratiques de mise en oeuvre de cette
aide nous avons également poussé pour
que l'indemnité carburant de travail
soit ouverte jusqu'au 6e des cils du
revenu fiscal de référence si la
finalement était préférée la poursuite
et la bonification de la remise
carburant nous sommes convaincus que
l'icité ne doit pas être remise dans les
cartons car il s'agissait d'un
dispositif bien pensé et bien cibler
enfin ce PLF est nécessaire parce que il
de financer d'autres priorités non moins
importantes et je pense notamment à la
nationalisation d'EDF en espérant
évidemment qu'elle permettent à notre
floron national de se projeter
pleinement dans l'avenir
j'en terminerai également on abordant la
question des 12 milliards d'euros qui
sont ajoutés pour financer la charge de
notre dette c'est un montant colossal
comme j'avais pu à l'exprimer lors de la
discussion générale et qui s'explique
par le double effet de remonter des taux
et de fortes inflation sur laquelle une
part de notre dette est indexée ces 12
milliards d'euros nous rappellent que la
situation a changé et que le
rétablissement des finances publiques
est et reste un enjeu de souveraineté et
de crédibilité nous avons eu l'occasion
de le dire lors de la présentation du
programme de stabilité et nous serons à
vos côtés messieurs les ministres lors
de l'examen de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques sur ce sujet
majeur mes chers collègues parce que ce
projet de loi de finance rectificative
des
passe par dans des mesures
indispensables et urgentes pour protéger
nos concitoyens nous le voterons
évidemment avec fierté et responsabilité
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Christine Arrighi
pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues le
groupe écologiste nupes votera contre ce
PLFR lors de cette lecture définitive un
projet de loi de finance rectificatif
comme celui que nous étudions impose une
approche claire et rigoureuse que l'on
soit contre les orientations du
gouvernement ou qu'on les soutienne sur
les recettes fiscales nous écologistes
avons proposé des solutions pour enfller
nos comptes comme pour alimenter nos
politiques publiques et insuffler
davantage de justice sociale et
environnementale ainsi avons-nous
soutenu la mise en place d'une taxation
que l'on pourrait qualifier en réalité
de solidarité de la part des très
grandes entreprises grandes
bénéficiaires de la période de crise
2020-2022 le gouvernement a balayé nos
propositions en première lecture tout
comme il a balayé une nouvelle fois
l'appui du groupe les républicains avec
l'appui du groupe les républicains les
propositions de nombreux sénateurs
un amendement qui venait aussi des
centrices du Sénat pourtant peu connu
pour leur conduite addictives pour les
prélèvements obligatoires du coup nous
accueillons avec une très grande
satisfaction une grande ville vigilance
l'installation à la demande du président
de la commission des finances de la
mission flash à laquelle je participe au
nom des écologistes sur les entreprises
pétrolières et gazières et du secteur du
transport maritime qui ont dégagé des
profits exceptionnels pendant la crise
et qui rendra ses conclusions à la
rentrée avant l'examen du projet de loi
de finance je parlais de recettes j'en
viens à celles que le gouvernement veut
supprimer également par idéologie en
supprimant la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public Vous portez une
atteinte grave au secteur public
audiovisuel car vous ne garantissez pas
avec un manque sérieux patent le
financement futur est donc
l'indépendance de médiathèques du JDL
numérique et radiophoniques venons
venons-en aux dépenses annoncé par la
première ministre comme une
nationalisation en opération marketing
de la novlang macroniste la
recapitalisation de déesse n'est en fait
en réalité que la première étape de
l'engagement d'un programme nucléaire au
coût exorbitant non rentables et
dangereux en période de réchauffement
climatique qui sera développé au
détriment d'un investissement massif
dans les énergies renouvelables énergie
renouvelable qui elle peuvent alimenter
un mix énergétique cohérent et qui
assurerait la création d'emplois
diversifiés et de reconversion
industrielle autrement mieux répartis
sur nos territoires allant de centre de
recherche comme à Toulouse par exemple
ou à des lieux de déploiement de ses
compétences sur tout le territoire
français constituant ainsi le maillage
d'une véritable planification écologique
à l'initiative de la puissance publique
mes chers collègues toujours sur les
dépenses il faut bien entendu des
mesures d'urgence pour aider les ménages
comme la prolongation du gel des tarifs
réglementés du gaz entre groupes les a
d'ailleurs votés nous avons aussi
contribué au soutien des collectivités
territoriales nous avons démontré que
les compromis spécifiques sont possibles
pour peu qu'ils soient préparés et
travailler mais ou sans les mesures
structurelles fortes ce texte demeure
d'une neutralité consternante et ne
comporte aucune disposition relative aux
économies d'énergie et il persiste dans
l'erreur avec le maintien sans condition
des baisses d'un pro de production c'est
pourtant bien le moment d'aider les
ménages engagés des rénovations globales
de leur habitation en vue d'une
meilleure isolation à tout le moins de
remplacer leur chaudière et de booster
d'autre part les entreprises et leur
sous-traitants qui font le choix
impérieux de la sobriété de la
rénovation thermique nous avons émis des
propositions en ce sens vous les avez
toutes rejetées en première lecture à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat
les écologistes s'opposent par ailleurs
vivement la politique antisociale de
systémique vu avec le PFR au seul prisme
de la commission des finances
vous entérinez la monétisation totale
des RTT sans condition explicite de
négociation collective vous ouvrez ainsi
au milieu de l'été en catimini une boîte
de Pandore en portant une atteinte grave
à la loi sur la réduction de temps de
travail sous couvert de volontariat et
vous êtes tendez les possibilités de
recours aux heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées ceux de façon inégalitaire
selon les entreprises et pour certains
salariés qui dans un contexte de
stagnation salariale et d'inflation ne
pourront que s'y résoudre volontairement
le tout bien entendu au détriment du
partage du temps du travail des contes
de l'état de la sécurité sociale et
d'une concurrence régulée entre
entreprises nous exprimons ainsi notre
plus grande indignation sur l'adhésion
des droites à une obsession de l'extrême
droite la carte Vitale biométrique soit
disant source de milliards d'économies
de lutte contre toutes les fraudes c'est
se moquer de la vraie fraude et de la
réalité de la vraie fraude la fraude
fiscale évaluée entre 80 et 100
milliards se moquaient des
professionnels de santé c'est surtout
insulter nos concit devient tout autant
que les étrangers résidents d'autres
pays qui participent à notre richesse et
qui ont au roi notre solidarité ce bel
effet constitue malheureusement un
inquiétant signal pour l'avenir nous
redisons aux Français conscients de la
situation climatique d'un régression
sociale en marche forcée oui vous pouvez
compter sur nous écologiste partout pour
vous représenter et défendre vos
intérêts ceux des générations futures
vos enfants nos enfants je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marc
Tellier pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègue nous arrivons
à l'issue de l'examen des projets de loi
jumeaux du pouvoir d'achat et de
finances rectificative dans une
trajectoire similaire les deux textes
ont été le fruit d'un arrangement
logique entre les composantes de la
droite la majorité présidentielle et les
républicains
il traduisent tous deux une fuite en
avant dangereuse visant à détricoter
d'une part les services publics de
l'État social et de l'autre part le
droit les droits sociaux et la
protection des salariés la faiblissement
des services publics et de l'état social
c'est bien entendu la politique de la
caisse vide mise en place depuis 5 ans à
coups de baisse d'impôts que vous
poursuivez encore avec ce PLFR avec pour
alibi la crise du pouvoir d'achat à
laquelle nous concitoyens font face
refusant de contraintes les entreprises
à augmenter les salaires seule solution
pour répondre efficacement à la poussée
de
l'inflationnisme l'État se substitue à
ces dernières en accordant baisse
d'impôts défiscalisation suppression des
cotisations sociales
il en résulte une perte des recettes
pour l'État qui viendra soit
éliminer le déficit alimenté excusez-moi
le déficit public soit c'est le plus
vraisemblable justifié des nouvelles
coupes dans les dépenses la suppression
de la contribution de l'audiovisuel
public dans cette logique alors même que
la redevance grand garantit c'est
l'indépendance de notre service public
audiovisuel vous la supprimer sur
l'Hôtel du pouvoir d'achat suite à votre
refus d'agir sur les salaires dans
l'immédiat il en résulte une hausse du
déficit public puisque cette suppression
sera comblée par une recette déjà
existante la TVA qui finance donc déjà
d'autres besoins ailleurs à terme
cependant nous ne doutons pas que
l'ajustement se verra pas
la baisse du financement de
l'audiovisuel public est donc par un
ajustement de la qualité des services et
des contenus la hausse du plafond des
heures supplémentaires ainsi que la
monétisation
défiscalisée des RTT participe également
de cette logique en poursuivant le
subventionnement du travail par la
puissance publique en lieu et place des
entreprises et ce pour plusieurs
milliards d'euros en agissant de la
sorte vous affaiblissez un peu plus le
financement de l'État et de la sécurité
sociale en outre vous refusez de
compenser ces pertes de recettes par de
nouveaux prélèvements alors même que ces
derniers sont parfaitement
légitimes comme la rappeler hier le
secrétaire général des Nations Unies
les
surprofits de certains total et une
grande partie des sièges du CAC 40
constituent une provocation et appelle
inéluctablement à une mesure de
solidarité à laquelle vous serez obligé
un jour ou l'autre de consentir l'autre
fuite en avant c'est bien entendu le
cadeau que vous venez de faire à la
droite qui a tout à fait depuis plus
près de 20 ans pour détruire les 35
heures avec les RTT
monétiser et les heures supplémentaires
des socialisés défiscalisés vous venez
de lui offrir le démantèlement du plus
grand progrès social de notre société
par un chantage
vicieux et profitant de la crise du
pouvoir d'achat ces mesures inciteront
les salariés à davantage de travail pour
pouvoir non pas gagner plus mais tout
juste garder la tête hors de l'eau les
mesures antisociales sont désormais
devenues votre marque de fabrique votre
caractéristique politique avec celle-ci
vous avez réussi vous réussissez le coût
parfait faire travailler encore plus les
français tout en refusant gourmander les
salaires ajoutons à cela l'absence de
toute mesure pour les jeunes et les
étudiants qui continuent de faire la
queue dans les banques alimentaires et
que vous semblez avoir abandonné ce PFR
tout comme le projet de loi de pouvoir
d'achat ne résoudra en rien l'urgence
sociale de notre pays il regroupe il
regroupe
il regroupe en revanche un cocktail de
mesure dangereux pour nos services
publics et
rétrogrades du point de vue des droits
sociaux le groupe GDR votre a donc
contre ce texte antisocial
je vous remercie avant de donner la
parole aux deux dernières orateurs
inscrits je vous rappelle que la
Conférence des Présidents a décidé qu'il
serait procédé à un scrutin en la forme
solennelle sur ce projet de loi tel qui
suit des conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire donc je fais annoncer le
scrutin public dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale et j'appelle
Monsieur Charles de Courson pour le
groupe liotte
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce président ce rapporteur
général mes chers collègues l'accord
trouvé en CMP d'année dernière sur ce
budget rectificatif rappelle une vertu
si souvent oubliée ces dernières années
la recherche d'un compromis
nous pouvons débattre intensément c'est
cela la démocratie et nous avons pu
rappeler à l'exécutif que l'Assemblée
nationale n'est plus une chambre
d'enregistrement c'est une victoire du
Parlement
pour autant c'est l'accord trouvant en
CMP acte des améliorations notables le
texte final est à certains égards
défaillants je commencerai par les
évolutions positives qui rendront du
pouvoir d'achat aux Français notre
groupe s'allume compromis trouver sur la
nouvelle aide exceptionnelle de rentrée
pour les prêts de 8 millions de foyers
les plus modestes à rebours de certains
discours nous nous refusons opposés
précaires et travailleurs modeste nous
disons cela alors que nous aurons à
examiner à la rentrée une nouvelle
réforme du Code du travail et de
l'assurance chômage il importait donc
d'assurer un versement de l'aide de
rentrer pour les bénéficiaires de
prestations sociales et pour ce
bénéficiaire de la prime d'activité
c'est ainsi que nous concevons la
solidarité nationale ce texte valorisé
également les prestations sociales et
les pensions de base c'est positives
même si c'est revalorisation reste
inférieur à l'inflation qui approchera
les 7% à la fin de cette année mais ce
que soulignait notre amendement d'appel
le fameux amendement à 500 millions
revalorisant les pensions de retraite
il aura au moins permis d'obtenir
l'engagement du ministre pour une
revalorisation dès le 1er janvier 2023 à
hauteur du différentiel d'inflation
constaté fin décembre s'agissant des
collectivités territoriales notre groupe
suit initier une règle logique de
compensation que neige entendu mes chers
collègues en commission lorsque mes
amendements ont été adoptés certains ont
dit c'est un irresponsable
s'adressant à moi je dirais c'est un peu
excessif comme propos
et c'est assez amusant puisque notre
groupe peut saluer le maintien de notre
amendement de compensation à l'euro près
de la revalorisation du RSA pour les
départements soit 120 millions et nous
attendons monsieur le ministre sa
consolidation messieurs les ministres
dans le budget 2023 auteur de 240
millions nous avons également initié une
analogue à des décisions du bloc
communal et après bien des péripéties la
nouvelle enveloppe de 430 millions
d'euros votés au Sénat permettra de
soutenir les communes les plus en
difficulté en particulier dans les zones
rurales en outre-mer Monsieur le
Ministre Jean vient maintenant aux
failles de ce texte elles sont
nombreuses
première critique où sont les mesures
ciblées
lorsque les comptes publics sont dans le
rouge et ils le sont avec un déficit
structurel de 3,6 points de pipes
d'après vos estimations il faut dépenser
efficacement cibler en priorité des
foyers et les travailleurs les plus
modestes notre groupe regrette fortement
votre choix d'abandonner cette ambition
de justice et d'efficacité de la dépense
publique qui était dans votre texte
initial monsieur le ministre vous le
faites avec la remise à la pompe
temporaire de 30 centimes mais monsieur
le ministre vous disiez que vous ne
vouliez pas je cite d'un compromis qui
s'achète à coup de milliards mais c'est
hélas ce qui a été fait
deuxième critique les adaptations les
modulations selon les territoires sont
insuffisantes où est la France rurale et
où sont les outre-mer alors comme
toujours depuis 5 ans le gouvernement
fonctionne dans une logique centralisée
et uniformisée avec ces textes nous
entrons dans la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens or nous devons voir qu'en
zone rural dans les territoires
ultramarins et insulaires les salaires
sont plus bas et l'inflation plus
élevées sur les carburants sur les
produits alimentaires même parfois nous
avons obtenu quelques avancées monsieur
le ministre et je pense au 15 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour l'aide
alimentaire en outre-mer à l'initiative
de notre collègue Estelle Youssoupha
nous regrettons cependant que le
gouvernement n'est pas voulu reconnaître
les difficultés spécifiques qui frappent
la Corse et qui impose une adaptation
des dispositifs notre groupe ne demande
pas des passes droits des mesures plus
équitables qui me prennent en compte les
réalités vécues par les Français
troisième critique monsieur le ministre
nous avons dépassé c'est vous qui l'avez
dit la juste raison la cote d'alerte sur
les finances publiques notre groupe
s'inquiète de voir la dette publique
rester un niveau dangereusement élevé
sans 12% du pipe alors même que les taux
d'intérêt remontent très rapidement le
programme de stabilité 2022 nous
confirme d'ailleurs qu'aucune avait les
ration des prévus d'ici 2027 que se
passera-t-il messieurs les ministres
avec cette rapide remontant des taux je
rappelle que la charge de la dette
procrassera pour la seule année 2022 de
17 milliards et puis quatrième critique
la suppression de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public là encore supprimer
cette impôt
on peut en discuter le vrai problème
c'est le financement de devisuel public
pour respecter son indépendance merci de
conclure au regard de tous ces éléments
notre groupe ne votera pas contre ce
texte considérant ces avancées pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Français les uns
s'abstiendront les
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Mathieu
Lefebvre pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente messieurs les ministres
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances sur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues la raison l'a
emporté ce qui paraissait impossible il
y a un mois l'adoption d'un texte à
l'issue d'une CMP favorable dénaturées
ni politiquement ni budgétairement et
devenu possible grâce à l'ensemble des
forces raisonnables de ce Parlement on
nous promettait le bruit et la fureur on
l'a eu pour partie mais nous avons eu la
modération et le travail inlassable de
compromis de notre rapporteur général
que je veux saluer ici
on nous disait incapable d'élargir notre
majorité et ce texte a été largement
approuvé sur ses bancs en première
lecture et le Sénat a effectué un
travail précieux pour l'améliorer je
tiens ici à saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité qui a prévu
contre toutes les vocifération de ceux
qui n'ont que les maux de taxe et
d'impôts à la bouche avec les
parlementaires raisonnables nous avons
tenu et nous avons tenu bon parce que
savoir tenir ses engagements à une
valeur politique contre toutes les
propositions les plus dispendieuses et
non financées avec les parlementaires
raisonnables nous avons tenu parce que
savoir dire non a aussi mes chers
collègues une valeur politique
mes chers collègues je ne peux donc que
me réjouir de ce travail de concert au
service du pouvoir d'achat des français
de la protection des plus modestes
d'entre eux de la baisse des impôts et
de la revalorisation du travail non
seulement ce texte n'est pas dénaturés
politiquesment puisqu'il continue de
servir ses 4 objectifs mais il ne l'est
pas non plus budgétairement dans la
mesure où latin de nos objectifs de
finances publiques n'étant aucun cas
remise en cause c'est aussi cela la
nouvelle méthode voulue par le président
de la République pour ce nouveau
quinquennat la sobriété parlementaire
par les peu par les moins forts mais
agir et agir beaucoup au service des
Français
oui quand avec le Sénat nous supprimons
la contribution à l'audiovisuel public
en accordant toutes les garanties
indispensables à l'indépendance du
secteur nous faisons oeuvre utile oui
quand avec le Sénat nos améliorons la
lutte contre les fraudes avec la mise en
place de la facturation électronique et
le développement de la carte Vitale
biométrique nous faisons œuvre utile oui
quand avec le Sénat nous adoptons des
mesures aussi essentielles pour la
valeur de travail que la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires et la
possibilité de racheter crtt nous
faisons œuvre utile et quand avec le
Sénat nous améliorons la prise en charge
par l'employeur des frais de transport
de ces salariés nous faisons œuvres
utile
je veux de ce point de vue revenir sur
les contre vérités qui ont émaillé ces
débats la première et le ministre Bruno
Le Maire l'a rappelé avec force il y a
pas un parlementaire de la majorité qui
souhaite remettre en cause la durée
légale du temps de travail je rappelle
que l'amendement l'amendement de notre
collègue Marc Ferracci c'est excellent
amendement il repose sur la base du
volontariat pour le salarié et sur la
base de l'accord de l'employeur je sais
pas ce que vous comprenez pas dans le
mot volontariat mais il me semble
extrêmement clair liberté d'un côté
caricature de l'autre et deuxièmement
nous avons entendu beaucoup de
contre-vérités sur la suppression de la
redevance télé enfin la contribution
l'audiovisuel public certains nous
disent mais vous allez financer cette
suppression d'impôts par d'autres impôts
par la TVA la vérité c'est qu'il y a
d'un côté cette majorité qui supprime et
qui baisse les taxes et de l'autre des
oppositions qui n'ont à la bouche que
les mots de redevance d'impôts et de
taxes c'est ça la vérité
[Applaudissements]
si je déplore les postures outrancières
et caricaturales que certains dans cette
hémicycle n'ont eu de 16 d'adopter tout
au long des débats je me félicite que
l'esprit de responsabilité est comme
toujours emporté sur la démagogie nous
parlons peut-être moins fort que vous
mais les résultats concrets que nous
avons obtenus ont un prix un prix dans
l'océan
dimocéan pardonnez-moi des modération
qui nous entoure et je voudrais
également de ce point de vue saluer
l'ouverture d'esprit dont on fait preuve
le gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle sur ce texte les deux
exemples les deux exemples des
carburants et des collectivités locales
sont de ce point de vue éloquent et ces
exemples il prouvent que si des
solutions raisonnables émergent de ces
bancs pour se substituer à celle prévue
par l'exécutif et bien nous sommes prêts
à l'examen accepter c'est ça la science
du compromis et elle nécessite aussi des
agents du compromis
j'en profite donc pour saluer les
ministres qui sont succédés au banc et
qui sont eux les artisans eux aussi les
artisans de ce compromis
voilà mes chers collègues les raisons
pour lesquelles le groupe Renaissance
votera avec ferveur se texte budgétaire
cohérent fidèle aux engagements du
Président de la République en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat des Français en faveur
de la valeur travail face à l'urgence
inflationniste et compatible avec
l'indispensable redressement de nos
comptes je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Kevin mot vieux
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues commençons dans ce PLF par le
bilan gloubiboulga pour reprendre
l'expression de Monsieur le Ministre le
maire quand il parle des dépenses des
autres
dégradation de plus de 14 milliards
d'euros du budget malgré un gavage sur
le dos des Français qui augmente lui de
plus de 31 milliards d'euros par rapport
à la prévision oui mes chers collègues
notre gouvernement trouve le moyen de
s'endetter toujours plus même avec des
recettes bien plus importantes que prévu
prise de surcroît sur le dos des
Français car en grande partie en
provenance des réservoirs automobiles de
nos concitoyens oui depuis des mois le
pistolet de la station-service n'a
jamais aussi bien porté son nom pompant
au nom d'une macronie méprisante le
budget des Français
ajoutons
ajoutons à cette dérive budgétaire la
part des 11% de titres indexés sur
l'inflation dont la France va devoir
s'acquitter dans les années à venir les
intérêts de la dette vont peser plus
lourd que ce que vous décidez pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Français venons-en
maintenant aux mesures commençons par le
positif la fin de l'ardevance sur
l'audiovisuel public mais dommage le
négatif revient déjà au galop vous ne
privatisez pas alors les Français
doivent comprendre ce que cela veut dire
leurs impôts vont continuer à financer
ce service mais avec une fraction de TVA
qu'il faudra bien combler alors je me
pose une question est-ce que votre refus
de baisser la TVA notamment sur les
carburants n'est pas en réalité la
future recette déguisée pour
l'audiovisuel public
et vous continuez dans le mépris des
Français et de leur pouvoir d'achat en
effet un certain nombre d'amendements
reprenant le projet le projet pardon du
rassemblement national pour augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des Français vous
balayez tous ces amendements d'un revers
de la main au motif de leur coup mais
vous n'avez pas le monopole de la bonne
dépense au mieux nous vous octroyons le
monopole de la dette
effectivement vous endettez le pays à
Tours de milliards comme les 12
milliards soit disant pour
recapitaliser EDF une entreprise dont on
est déjà majoritaire ce qui représente
la moitié du budget pouvoir d'achat pour
un pseudo rachat quand vous mais quand
nous voulons nous pardon rendre leur
argent aux Français là d'un coup la
dette vous revient à l'esprit baisser
les taxes sur les carburants vous le
refusez et pire vous tentez d'arnaquer
les Français vous pensez vous faire une
grande pub en annonçant une remise par
Total mais en réalité vous faites une
grande pub pour totale car les Français
dans leur grande majorité font leur
plein en supermarché et non chez Total
sur les autoroutes nous adressons donc
nos sincères félicitations au groupe
Total qui s'est offert un spot de pub
gratuitement sponsorisé par le
gouvernement français
supprimer la TVA sur les produits de
première nécessité vous le refusez
également parce que ça ne joue pas sur
les prix alors je me pose la question
aujourd'hui pourquoi il y a des taux
différents si le prix n'est jamais
impacté
taxez les surprofis des profiteurs de
crise et de guerre vous le balayez d'un
revers de la main également alors qu'il
s'agit d'une question de justice fiscale
et sociale et d'ailleurs petit coup de
projecteur sur l'extrême gauche nupes
qui refuse elle bien qu'elle nous
mobilise des nuits sur ce sujet de voter
notre amendement pour taxer les
surprofis
rétablir la demi part fiscale pour les
veuves et les veuves vous êtes contre et
avec un très grand mépris en parlant
dans votre discours de cadeau à
quelques-uns le mépris pour les veufs et
les œufs plus agaçant encore pour les
Français et pour nous qui les aimons
mais grâce à nous et contre vous malgré
vos tentatives anti-démocratiques de
retrait d'un amendement puis de nouveaux
votes sur un autre suite à un amer
revers il faut l'avouer nous retiendrons
que nous sommes parvenus à des avancées
pour notre pays d'abord même si vous
l'avez sérieusement édulcorer la
compensation pour les collectivités
territoriales des hausses de RSA et du
point d'indice des fonctionnaires en
effet les collectivités territoriales
n'ont pas vocation à financer ni la
dette de l'État ni le programme
présidentiel d'un candidat à la déroute
qui cherchait in extremis à acheter un
maximum de voix d'ailleurs je salue
l’avancée de la CMP qui a repassé ce
budget à 500 millions d'euros ensuite
même chose sur l'aide au foyer chauffant
au fioul votre bouclier tarifaire les
punissaient ils seront grâce à nous
aider et nous espérons bien que chaque
député Renaissance en circonscription
assumera auprès de ses électeurs qu'ils
ne voulaient pas les aider et qu'on lui
a forcé
alors mes chers collègues arrivent
maintenant le moment de se prononcer sur
ce texte le rassemblement national ne
pourra décemment pas voter ce texte mais
nous ne pouvons pas non plus par
cohérence nous y opposer en effet si
tout le mépris du gouvernement pour les
Français que contient ce texte nous a
vite à vouloir voter contre notre
responsabilité par rapport aux avancées
nous contraint à ne pas l'entraver nous
nous obtiendrons donc merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Mathilde panot
pour la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres collègues
la nuit était avancée il était deux
heures du matin elle emportait l'immense
et pénible songe des Milan du Moyen-Âge
l'aube qui commence à était celle de la
liberté depuis cette merveilleuse nuit
plus de classe des Français plus de
provinces une France
raconter ici par Michelet cette nuit
historique était celle du 4 août 1789
après des siècles de tyrannie sociale au
terme d'une longue nuit de débat les
députés constituants abolissaient les
privilèges collègues que reste-t-il de
cette nuit du 4 août si peu si ce n'est
notre combat pour la République sociale
que vous combattez avec tant de ferveur
la macronie et ses alliés de droite et
d'extrême droite s'emploie à restaurer
la société des privilèges et celle-ci
n'a pas de meilleur gardien que vous
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
années vous faisiez encore semblant de
gouverner pour l'intérêt général nous
écoutions alors d'une oreille distraite
vos sornettes sur le ruissellement le
temps du bilan est passé vous n'avez
désormais plus le bénéfice du doute non
l'argent des riches ne circule pas dans
l'équilibre non l'argent distribué aux
multinationales ne sert ni à augmenter
les salaires ni encourager
l'investissement ni à créer des emplois
oui tous vos cadeaux fiscaux s'échappent
en dividende et en spéculation
à présent nul besoin de vous cacher vous
avancez à visage découvert vous êtes
guidé par une seule conviction les plus
riches doivent faire nation à part vous
vous êtes nommé Renaissance sans doute
pour annoncer votre projet la
régénération d'une société de caste
après tout qui a besoin de Seigneur
quand en France un criminel climatique
comme Total n'a pas payé d'impôts sur
les sociétés ces dernières années et à
doubler ses bénéfices en un an quand
l'entreprise réalise un record de 18
milliards de profits mais fait l'aumône
de 500 millions d'euros français
étranglés par le prix de l'essence soit
0,2 % de son chiffre d'affaires qui a
besoin de Seigneur quand en France le
CAC 40 arrosé d'argent public sans
condition réalise 174 milliards d'euros
de bénéfices et redistribue 80 milliards
d'euros de dividendes à ses actionnaires
tandis que les PME sont deux fois plus
taxés que les grands groupes
qui a besoin de Seigneur quand en France
5 personnes possèdent autant que 27
millions de Français pendant que vu
culpabiliser les précaires et les
chômeurs vous avez écarté
l'une après l'autre toute forme de mise
à contribution des plus riches vous
refusez toujours de bloquer les prix
vous refusez de taxer les profiteurs de
crise vous refusez de rétablir l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune vous
refusez d'augmenter les salaires mais
vous proposer aux Français de revendre
leur être RTT pour arriver à finir les
fins de mois bienvenue en macronarchie
vous la répartition des richesses se
heurte à un caprice sémantique comprenez
collègues Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ici
présent abord le mot taxe et le mot
surprofit alors tant pis tant pis pour
les 10 millions de pauvres tant pis pour
les 8 millions de personnes qui relèvent
de l'aide alimentaire tant pis pour les
12 millions de personnes en précarité
énergétique tant pis pour les 13
millions de personnes qui peinent à se
déplacer faute de véhicule ou de
carburant trop cher ils ne pas à vos
yeux une raison suffisante pour renoncer
à l'engraissement d'une poignée au
détriment de tous finalement ce ne sont
pas les taxes que vous détestez monsieur
le ministre c'est la justice sociale le
4 août 1789 les constituants comme un
certain vicomte de Noël projeter la
France à l'avant-garde du programme
humain en Europe je le cite le royaume
flotte dans ce moment entre
l'alternative de la destruction de la
société ou d'un gouvernement qui sera
admiré et suivi de toute l'Europe
aujourd'hui le 4 août 2022 nous en
sommes à la remorque le FMI recommande
de taxer les super profits tout comme la
Commission européenne qu'on ne peut pas
qualifier de partager cette taxe est
prévue au Royaume-Uni en Italie et en
Espagne hier c'est le Secrétaire général
de l'Organisation des Nations Unies
Antonio gutherese lui-même qui souligne
la cupidité grotesque des entreprises
pétaulières qui se gavent sur le dos des
plus pauvres et appelle à son tour à une
taxe c'est super profit et Moro comme
vous êtes seul monsieur le ministre mais
vous vous obstinez vous engouffrez le
pays tout entier dans la compilité et
l'égoïsme social songez donc à ces mots
de Larousse le bonheur du peuple est
facile à faire quand ceux qui le
gouvernent s'occupent moins de même que
de lui alors Monsieur le Ministre
collègue cessez de vous préoccuper des
intérêts de vos amis les seigneurs
prenez goût à l'intérêt général soyez
enfin à la hauteur de notre histoire
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
nous en venons au texte de la commission
mixte paritaire
conformément à l'article 113 alinéa 3 du
règlement je vais d'abord appeler
l'assemblée à statuer sur quatre
amendements dont je suis saisie monsieur
le ministre est-ce que vous ne pouvez
nous les présenter globalement
oui très rapidement madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés il
s'agit de quatre amendements qui font
suite à l'accord trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire le premier l'amendement
numéro 4 et l'amendement au tableau
d'équilibre donc il tient compte dans
les équilibres financiers du texte des
décisions qui ont été prises au cours de
la commission mixte paritaire
l'amendement numéro 2 qui vient après et
les deux suivants vise à lever le gage
sur un certain nombre de mesures qui ont
été décidées à lors de la CMP sur
l'amendement numéro 2 il s'agit il
s'agit de 10 millions d'euros qui ont
été accordés pour soutenir la production
de lavande et de lavandin dans notre
pays dont la filière est en difficulté
pour pas que les 10 millions d'euros
soient pris sur le budget actuel de
l'agriculture nous levons le gage pour
10 millions d'euros supplémentaires
l'amendement numéro 1 lève le gage sur 5
millions d'euros qui vont venir financer
nos 10 dans les départements et
notamment financer des financer des
colonnes de renfort pour les pompiers
qui sont particulièrement mobilisés dans
un certain de territoires
cet été
et donc cet amendement lève le gage
puisque sinon les 5 millions d'euros
sont pris sur le budget de la
gendarmerie nationale et nous rageons
donc 5 millions d'euros et enfin le
dernier amendement permet de lever le
gâche sur les 100 millions d'euros qui
ont été décidés en commission mixte
paritaire pour permettre aux
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité de
bénéficier d'une aide exceptionnelle de
rentrée dans des conditions que nous
déterminerons avec les parlementaires le
gage est levé puisque les 100 millions
d'euros sinon étaient sur le programme
handicap et dépendance et donc nous
rajoutons 100 millions d'euros mais nous
restons au global comme la rappeler
Bruno Le Maire dans les pures financiers
de ce que nous avons à présenter c'est
un enjeu de responsabilité et on voit
bien que ça n'empêche pas les progrès
majeurs pour les Français
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
général votre avis sur ces quatre
amendements merci Madame la présidence
je vous les remercier le gouvernement de
levée segache ça n'était pas obligatoire
merci au gouvernement de respecter le
travail des parlementaires au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale à lui faire droit
pour les cartes
je vous remercie
j'ai une demande de prise de parole non
si si mais
d'abord on met la veste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
j'ai vu que certains s'écrit oh non vous
n'êtes pas encore en vacances chers
collègues ça va venir ne vous inquiétez
pas
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais simplement faire signaler
que lorsque à deux heures du matin
vous avez repris 500 millions d'euros au
retraité c'était parce que soit disant
il y avait un gage et ben je voulais
juste faire signaler que vous voyez que
quand on veut lever le gage on peut
lever le gage
je vous rappelle juste simplement que le
dernier vote sur votre loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat à retirer 500 millions
d'euros à nos retraités vous auriez dû
lever ce gage comme vous venez de lever
ces gages
[Applaudissements]
je vais mettre voix successivement ces
amendements donc le numéro 4 qui a reçu
un avis favorable comme une science ce
sont des votes à main levée d'abord qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté
l'amendement numéro 2 à vie favorable
également commission qui est pour qui
est contre il est adopté le 1 mais ma
vie même vote et le 3 même avis même
vote je vous remercie donc je vais
mettre voir le projet de loi de finance
rectificatif pour 2022 tel qu'il a été
issu des travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire et modifié par les amendements
qui viennent d'être adoptés tout le
monde a pu regagner sa place le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 510
exprimé 412 majorités 207 pour 292
contre 120 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté donc je vous indique que
l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
donc je vous indique que l'assemblée
achevé l'examen des taxes créés à son
ordre du jour je prendrai acte de la
clôture de la session extraordinaire par
avis publiée au Journal officiel et la
séance élevée merci mes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]